machine learning is the top Technologies
of the 21st century it brought
revolution in every sector like business
and more hello everyone welcome to this
full course video on machine learning by
simply learn this video will help you in
the concept and give you the ample hands
of experience building machine learning
models we have experienced instructor
who will take you through this course
but before we start let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech gig in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started
in today's session we will go through
intro to machine learning after that we
will move on to the types of machine
learning after this we will cover
supervised unsupervised reinforcement
learning one by one moving forward we
will see machine learning algorithms in
depth after that we will cover some
amazing projects on machine learning
like face detection
text to speech speech to text
then data analysis on top thousand
Instagram profile after that automatic
Excel with python machine learning then
movie recommendation followed by
sentiment analysis of Amazon customer
and Loan prediction system at last we
will see Parkinson's detection using
machine learning I hope you guys are
ready to learn something new so without
any further delay let's get started over
to our training expert
do you guys know from predicting the
weather condition by examining Cloud
designs in the baby long time in the
18th century BC to using electronic
messages phones analyzing satellite
images in the 20th century the process
of weather forecasting has evolved
essentially throughout the long term
however in this digitalized period
forecasting climate and recreating
long-term climate patterns have been
accomplished with the assistance of
machine learning models by examining
volumes of information by computer
so the question arises is it possible
for a machine to learn from past
efficiences just like we humans do
and the answer to this question is yes
and this became possible just because of
machine learning machine learning is a
subpart of artificial intelligence which
is broadly defined as capability of a
machine to imitate intelligent human
behavior
like humans learn from their past and
acquire knowledge through experience
either directly or shared by others
machine acquired knowledge through
experience shared in the form of data
let's understand with the basic idea of
how machine Learning Works
firstly you have to input the pass data
or training data into the machine
learning model
after that machine learning model learns
from the data and creates logical models
in the end when you input new data to a
machine learning model it predict output
according to the logical models
after understanding what machine
learning is the question arises why we
need machine learning
even though machine learning is
constantly developing with countless new
technologies it is still used in
different organizations machine learning
is important because it aims with a
perspective on patterns in user Behavior
operation design and support the
improvements of new products also as the
volume of data overperforms people move
in the direction of computerized systems
that store data and machine learning
models can predict proper solution this
will reduce human efforts time and
increase work efficiency
like Facebook Google Uber top
organization use make machine learning
as their masters too
machine learning has demonstrated
history in almost all the sectors like
marketing e-commerce Banking and many
others as of now we are well aware of
how machine learning is important let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantage of machine learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantage and disadvantage here are some
advantages of machine learning first one
is low error rate if coded properly
machine learning models could have a
lower rate as compared to humans machine
learning models have incredible Clarity
accuracy and speed second was in
automation
machine learning reduces the need for
human resources at every step as it
automatically learns and predicts the
output third one is wide range
application almost every sector takes
advantage of machine learning to reduce
human effort and get quick results
talking about Healthcare machine
learning is used for screening or to
predict healthy risk in healthcare
in education machine learning is used to
give each student an individual
educational experience or in banking
enables more accurate reporting by
automating creditors for both Banks and
customers the fourth one is Trends and
patterns identification we can identify
the numerous amount of Trends and
patterns for example the stock market
uses machine learning prediction model
to predict Trends and patterns for
companies talk and other Financial
assets
and the last one is continuous
Improvement using machine learning you
can see continuous Improvement in your
results machine learning is capable of
learning from the information we provide
them
as every coin has two sides machine
learning has advantages as well as
disadvantage let's have a look at some
disadvantages now the first one is
costly machine learning models are
expensive and time consuming to build
rebuild and repair the robotic repair
can reduce the time and Manpower
required to fix machine learning models
but again that is too pricey second one
is limited time and quality resources
machine learning needs a lot of data but
it also needs good quality data to learn
efficiently
the third one is storage
the backup and servers are continuous at
work and are responsible for recording
the acquired information this keeps on
building up the course for a machine to
learn the potential information is a
continuous activity thus there is a need
to store the information different
storages and cloud services are not
sufficient to store this amount of large
data and the last one is unemployment
machine replacing human jobs can lead to
several unemployment now that we have an
understanding of the advantages and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified into
first one is supervised learning second
one is unsupervised learning third one
is reinforcement learning fourth one is
semi-supervised learning let's
Understand Each one by one in detail
in supervised learning the machine is
trained with the help of label data with
external Guidance the machine learning
model is given a small preparation data
set to work with let's understand this
by example suppose we input data as an
image having known label data of dogs in
this way machine will learn and create
some logical models when we input a
known data the Machine model will
categorize them as per their
similarities and patterns that is we can
easily sort the unknown input as a dog
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two types first
one is classification second is
regression and the next one is
unsupervised learning
in unsupervised learning machine Act
without any guidance in this technique
machine act upon the data that is
neither classified nor labeled without
any external guidance for example
suppose we input data as an image having
both mango and banana which the machine
has never seen in this way the machine
has no clue about the characteristic of
mango and banana so we can't categorize
them as mango and banana yet it can
categorize them as their similarities
pattern and contrast that is we can
easily sort the above picture into two
parts
unsupervised learning can be further
classified into two types which are
clustering Association now let's have a
look at reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is hit and trial
method in the absence of any data the
machine is bound to learn from its
experience only
let's understand with an example suppose
we input the image of a square machine
learning model will respond using the
past experience suppose it gives output
as a circle
then feedback is provided as wrong it's
an image of a square now the machine
learning model will learn from this
feedback and it will predict the correct
output when we input the same image next
time
reinforcement learning can be further
classified into two types positive
reinforcement learning negative
reinforcement learning
and the last one is semi-supervised
learning semi-supervised learning is a
sort of machine learning algorithm that
lies between supervised and unsupervised
machine learning or it takes label and
unlabeled data to predict the outcomes
to beat the disadvantage of supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
algorithm the idea of semi-supervised
learning was presented
the principal point of semi-supervised
learning is to utilize accessible
information successfully after
discussing what machine learning is
importance of machine learning the
advantages and disadvantages of machine
learning and its types let's move
forward to see commonly used algorithm
and machine learning in computer
programming terms and the algorithm is a
set of well-defined instruction to solve
a particular problem
it takes a bunch of information sources
and delivers the ideal result in this
modern time there are lots of machine
learning algorithm used today in this
video we will put highlight the most
widely used machine learning algorithm
the first one is support Vector machine
algorithm also known as svm sum
algorithm falls under the supervised
machine learning technique next is the K
nearest neighbor algorithm it falls
under the unsupervised machine learning
technique further we have hierarchical
clusting algorithm which uses an
unsupervised machine learning technique
the last one is decision tree algorithm
which is most widely used algorithm in
the machine learning area the decision
tree algorithm falls under the
supervised machine learning technique
after this let's move forward to see
some tools used to train the models in
machine learning
the current market is flooded with an
array of machine learning tools like
tensorflow purchasinga spark Amazon
machine learning Python and many more
which help in training the models and
the system let's have a look at each of
them first we will start with tensorflow
tensorflow is a free and open source
programming library for machine learning
key features of tensorflow are fast
debugging scalable and many more Google
uses tensorflow to power machine
learning implementation in products like
search Gmail and Translate
and the next we have Apache singer a
Apache singer is an Apache top level
project it is used for developing an
open source machine learning library key
features of Apache singer are
distributive learning memory
optimization time profiling and many
more
is currently in use at corniest
Technologies City group and many others
in the next one we have Apache Spa
Apache spark is an open source pumped
together analytics engine Sparks come
with the features like pre-processing
data transformation and many more spark
machine learning tools power the Toyota
customer 360 inside platform and social
media Intelligence Center
in the next we have Amazon machine
learning tool the most promising
strength of AWS machine learning tool is
that they are based on a highly
comprehensive Cloud platform
Amazon machine learning comes with the
features like accurate prediction
reducing operation overhead improving
customer experience and many other many
pigments like Netflix and Facebook use
AWS as their machine learning service
and the last one we have python
pytorch is an open source machine
learning framework in view of torch
Library
features like distributive training a
robust ecosystem Cloud support and many
more
companies commonly using pythons are IBM
Qualcomm Walmart and many more
let's move forward and cover
applications of machine learning
knowingly or unknowingly machine
learning is playing a major role in our
day-to-day life here I have some
application of machine learning which
will improve how machine learning is
helping everyone all over the globe
we all use YouTube Netflix and Facebook
in our day-to-day life the machine
learning algorithm figures out the
patterns of what type of video movie we
watch and thus provide a solution
accordingly Tesla is the one of the best
companies which manufacture self-driving
cars using Electric solar and integrated
Renewable Energy Solutions caused by
Tesla are already making their way to
the market and ready to show the world
of the power Ai and machine learning
another application of machine learning
is speech recognization
we all aware of voice assistance like CD
by Apple Cortana by Microsoft and Alexa
by Amazon these assistant translate is
speech to text and use machine learning
to provide result
machine learning is also used in medical
sector to determine various diseases
with the help of machine learning the
patterns and the symptoms of disease can
easily be diagnosed
and the last one is forecasting weather
forecasting and financial forecasting
are application of machine learning in
which future outcomes are predicted
using historical data it involves the
use of statical modeling data mining
technique and machine learning for
prediction so as we have seen all the
major aspects of machine learning we
will finally have a look at the future
of machine learning the commercial
impacts of machine learning can really
hold a huge potential to generate
significantly High productivity growth
machine learning is one of the quickest
developing field on this planet at the
present time machine learning Engineers
are in high demand the average salary of
machine learning engineers in India is 9
lakh per annum and the annual base pay
for U.S machine learning Engineers is
one like thirty thousand dollar all the
ventures as of now have countless usage
in machine learning which is the
fundamental inspiration behind why there
is an interest for occupation in that
field the growth in technology has that
in increasing demand for professionals
who can understand and make use of the
vast amount of data present companies
like Facebook Google Tesla and many more
are constantly hiring machine learning
engineers
the future of machine learning looks
bright and will pave the path to many
more invention
now let's look into the types of machine
learning
machine learning is primarily of three
types first one is supervised machine
learning as the name suggests you have
to supervise your machine learning while
you train it to work on its own it
requires labels training data next up is
unsupervised learning wherein there will
be training data but it won't be labeled
finally there's reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train
this is how the training is done we
provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know that these pictures
where that of a fruit called Apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do is we provide a new set of data
which only contains pictures of Apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you what fruit it is
and it will remember this and apply this
knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
into filtering spam mails from your
email accounts as well yes surprise
aren't you
so let's move on to unsupervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work simple isn't it this kind of a
model is used by Flipkart to figure out
the products that are well suited for
you honestly speaking this is my
favorite type of machine learning out of
all the three and this type has been
widely shown in most of the Sci-Fi
movies lately let's find out how it
works imagine a newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burned
so it does that anyway and gets hurt the
next time you put that candle in front
of the baby it will remember what
happened the last time and would not
repeat what it did that's exactly how
reinforcement learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify a
particular kind of a fruit in this case
an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango but as we all know
it's a completely wrong answer so as a
feedback we tell the system that it's
wrong it's not a mango it's an apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us the right answer it
is able to tell us that it's actually an
apple that is a reinforced response so
that's how reinforcement learning works
it learns from its mistakes and
experiences
this model is used in games like Prince
of Persia or Assassin's Creed or FIFA
wherein the level of difficulty
increases as you get better with the
games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning firstly the
data involved in case of supervised
learning is labeled as we mentioned in
the examples previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data because
its work is to look for patterns in the
input data and organize it
the next point is that you get a
feedback in case of supervised learning
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point is that
supervised learning is mostly used to
predict data whereas unsupervised
learning is used to find out hidden
patterns or structures in data
I think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
chain learning is the art of making
computers learn and act like humans by
fitting data and which focuses on
utilization of information and imitating
the way that people learn step by step
working on its accuracy
machine learning is playing a major role
in our day-to-day life machine learning
is used in Trends and pattern
identification automation weather
forecasting and many more
machine learning is classified into
supervised machine learning unsupervised
machine learning reinforcement learning
semi-supervised learning
let's understand supervised machine
learning in detail
provides machine learning machines are
trained using label data also known as
training data to predict the results
here labeled data refers to a group of
data that have been tagged with one or
more names and data is already known to
the machine
supervised machine learning can be used
for image and object recognition
Predictive Analytics customer sentiment
analysis spam detection and many more
after understanding what supervised
machine learning is let's move forward
and see how supervised machine Learning
Works
suppose we have a data set that includes
dogs and cats now the first step is that
we need to train the model for each dogs
and cats as per the factors like
similarity pattern shapes and contrast
now after training we test our model
using new data set which is unknown to
the model and the task of the model is
to identify the new input data the
machine is already trained on all types
of similarity patterns shapes and
contrast
when it finds new data it classifies it
on the basis of simulatory patterns
shapes and contracts and predict the
output
as of now we are well aware of how
supervised machine Learning Works let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantages of supervised machine
learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantages and disadvantages here are
some advantages of supervised machine
learning first one is real world
competition problems help you to solve
various types of real world competition
problems like spam detection image and
objects recognition and many more the
second one is optimization using past
experience supervised machine learning
can optimize performance criteria the
third one is prediction
in supervised machine learning models
can predict the output based on the past
experience as well fourth one is
reusable data we can reuse the training
data unless there is any future change
supervised machine learning has
advantages as well as disadvantages
let's have a look at some disadvantages
now
computation time is also known as
running time is very vast for the
supervised machine learning supervised
machine learning models always need
updates
reprocessing of data a big challenge for
predicting the output anyone can overlap
supervised machine learning easily it
occurs when a statical model is exactly
against its training data now that we
have an understanding of advantage and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of supervised
machine learning
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two problems
which are classification integration
let's see them one by one in detail
classification is a process of in which
new observations are recognized and
separated in such a way that they can be
categorized assuming you have a group of
things for example vegetables you can
categorize them based on their property
that they have like you can arrange the
potatoes in class A tomatoes in class B
capsicum in class C
these are some popular classification
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning first one is random
Forest second decision trees third one
is logistic regression fourth one is
support Vector machines
moving forward let's have a look on
regression
a regression algorithm is used to figure
out the connection between a dependent
and independent variables dependent
variables are nothing but a variables
which we are trying to predict are
forecast and independent variables means
that factors that influence the analysis
it is usually used to make projection
for example we have variable one as
humidity and variable towards
temperature where humidity will play the
role of dependent variable and in
temperature will be the independent
variable humidity and temperatures are
correlated in such a way that as
temperature increases commodity will
decrease and vice versa many
organization utilize regression models
to predict how stocks will act from here
on this is done by breaking down the
past information on stock costs and
Trends to recognize pattern these are
some popular regression algorithms that
comes under supervised machine learning
first one is linear regression second
one is digression trees third one is
non-linear regression boards one is
Bayesian linear regression after
discussing the advantages and
disadvantages of supervised machine
learning and its types let's move
forward to see algorithms in supervised
machine learning
in computer programming terms an
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem it takes a bunch of information
sources and delivers the ideal result
the first supervised machine learning
algorithm is linear regression linear
regression is equalized to recognize the
connection between dependent variable
and at least one independent variable
and is commonly utilized to make
forecasts about future results company
frequently use linear regression models
to predict future sales this can be
useful for things like planning and
arranging algorithms like Amazon product
to product collaborative filtering are
utilized to predict what clients will
purchase later on given their past
purchase history
a regression tree is worked through a
cycle known as binary recursive
partitioning which is an alternative
interaction that divides the information
into segments of branches and afterwards
keep splitting each data into smaller
groups as the technique claims each
branch these trees are used for
dependent variables with continuous
value for example a regression tree
named food which divides into segments
veg and non-width further it keeps
splitting into smaller groups
non-linear regression is a type of
regression examination wherein
information is fit to model and
afterward communicated as a numerical
function simple linear regression
relates to factors with a straight line
while non-linear regression relates to
two factors in a non-linear relationship
non-linear regression can be used to
predict population growth over time or
the relationship between GDP and the
time of a country
this algorithm is a way to deal with
linear regression in which this statical
examination is attempted inside the
settings of patient inference linear
equation and patient regression can
generate the same prediction and with
the help of patient processing we can
retrieve the complete variety of
inferential solution instead of Quant
estimate
random Forest is one of the most
adaptable supervised machine learning
algorithm utilized for both
classification and regression purposes
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication it is utilized to predict the
things which assist these businesses
with running productively like client
activity patient history and safety
a dissidenty is a very specific sort of
tree that empowers you to conclude some
kind of process used for dependent
variables prediscreet values for example
we want to pick between manufacturing
product a or product b or putting
resources into Decision One decision two
or decision three decision trees are an
outstanding method for managing these
kinds of complex choices
Logistics regression is calculated
logically and chosen when the dependent
variable is category meaning they have
double results for example logistic
regression can be used to print whether
a political nominee will win or lose a
political race or regardless of whether
a secondary school student will be
admitted up to a specific School
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for the two information
classification and regression all things
considered it is regularly utilized for
grouping issues like weekend involvement
different Life Care Systems we can
involve in typically happy and sad look
arrangement you can involve in filters
if you make specific looks it would add
the particular filter according to the
expression the scope of articulation
lies between happy and sad after
understanding supervised machine
learning algorithms let's move forward
and cover applications of supervised
machine learning choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
to provide machine learning models can
be used to build and Advance several
businesses application including the
following the first one is image and
object recognition supervised machine
learning models can be utilized to find
isolate and assault objects out of
recordings of pictures making them
valuable when applied to different
computer design strategies and imaginary
analysis the second one is predictive
analysis a broad use case provides
machine learning models is in making
Predictive Analytics systems to give
profound experience into different
business data of Interest this permits
to expect specific outcomes because of a
given result variable assisting Business
Leaders to justify choices or turn to
sub the association
the third one is customer sentiment
analysis utilizing supervised machine
learning models Association can extract
and arrange significant pieces of data
from huge volumes of information
including context emotion and purpose
with very little human intervention
this can be incredibly valuable while
acquiring a superior understanding of
blinded collaboration and can be
utilized to further develop brand
engagement efforts the fourth one is
Spam detection spam identification is
another application of supervised
machine learning model utilizing
classification calculation companies can
prepare data sets to recognize patterns
or anomalies and new information to sort
out spam and non-spam related data
unsupervised learning is a machine
learning technique used to train the
machine learning algorithm using data
that is either unclassified or unlabeled
and allows the algorithm to act on that
data without guidance unlabeled data is
a designation for pieces of data that
have not been tagged with labels
identified by characteristics Properties
or classifications
so the flow of unsupervised learning
starts with training data that has no
labels and depends on the feature Vector
the machine learning model defines the
predictive model this is tested with an
individual subset of data with its own
feature Vector here the predictive model
defines the likelihood or cluster ID or
a better representation of unlabeled
data
let's look at the difference between
unsupervised and supervised learning
supervised a learning technique deals
with label data where the output data
patterns are known to the system
unsupervised learning works with
unlabeled data in which the output is
just based on the collection of
perceptions
supervised learning method is less
complex the unsupervised learning method
is more complex supervised learning
conducts offline analysis unsupervised
learning performs real-time analysis
the outcome of the supervised learning
technique is comparatively more accurate
and reliable unsupervised learning
generates moderately acute but reliable
results
while classification and regression are
the types of problems solved under the
supervised learning method
unsupervised learning includes
clustering and associative rule mining
problems
example and application of unsupervised
learning let's understand unsupervised
learning through an example
consider a scenario where a child had no
learning phase and is shown images
without the labels now if the child is
asked to identify if any range is a bird
or an animal he will lack the
information that can help him do so the
best he can do is come up with the
following groups based on common
patterns wings and legs for example this
explains how unsupervised Learning Works
we show a lot of data to our algorithm
and ask it to find patterns in the data
by itself
let's look at the application of
unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning can be used for
anomaly detection as well as clustering
to understand clustering let's look at a
simple real life example a mother asks
her two children to arrange the pieces
of plain blocks the children come up
with two different groups as shown with
different similarities in the blocks
this is clustering each of our children
came up with a different type of
grouping one child grouped them based on
the shape whereas the other grouped them
based on the color there is no right or
wrong way
then how can you pick one set of
clusters over the others
this will depend on the similarity
measure used by the mother in this case
the arrangement of child one is better
than child two if the similarity measure
chosen by the mother was that blocks
should have the same shape however the
arrangement by Child 2 is better if the
similarity measure chosen by the mother
was that blocks should have the same
color therefore defining the similarity
measure is important when performing
clustering there may be different ways
in which data can be arranged in
different groups based on size shape
color texture and other complex features
anomaly detection is a clustering
technique used to identify unusual
patterns that do not conform to expected
Behavior anomaly detection has many
applications in business such as
intrusion detection system Health
monitoring and fraud detection
clustering
the method of grouping similar entities
together is called clustering the goal
of this unsupervised machine learning
method is to seek out similarities
within the data points and a cluster
similar data points together
need for clustering let's look at the
need for clustering grouping similar
entities together helps to merge the
attributes of different clusters in
other words this gives us insight into
underlying patterns of different groups
there are a lot of applications of
grouping unlabeled data for example in
order to maximize the revenue you can
identify different groups or clusters of
customers and Market to each group in a
different way another example is
grouping books together that belong to
similar topics clustering is needed to
determine the intrinsic grouping in a
set of unlabeled data
organize data into clusters that show
internal structure of the data partition
the data points understand and extract
value from large sets of structured and
unstructured data types of clustering
there are two types of clustering
hierarchical clustering and partitional
clustering hierarchical clustering can
be agglomerative and divisive whereas
partitional clustering can be K means
and fuzzy c means a distinction among
different types of clustering is whether
the set of clusters is nested or
unnested
a partitional clustering is just a
division of the set of data objects into
non-overlapping sets or clusters such
that every data object is in just one
subset a hierarchical clustering is a
tree structure that has a set of nested
clusters
hierarchical clustering the output of
hierarchical clustering is a hierarchy
how does they hire archical clustering
form a hierarchy assume you are going to
create a three-layer hierarchy from six
different data nodes so first combine A
and B based on similarity and also
combine d and e based on similarity
combination of A and B is combined with
C in the similar way combination of d
and e is combined with f now combine C
and F inside one cluster when you look
at the final tree it contains all
clusters combined into a single cluster
let's understand the working of
hierarchical clustering it works in four
steps step one assign each item to its
own cluster such that if you have n
number of items you will have n number
of clusters step two merge two clusters
into a single cluster by finding the
closest pair of clusters now you will
have one cluster less step three compute
distances between the new cluster and
all old clusters step 4 repeat steps two
and three until all items are clustered
into a single cluster of size n
let's understand the distance measure in
hierarchical clustering let's look at
the different kinds of linkage in
clustering complete linkage clustering
it finds the maximum distance between
points belonging to two different
clusters
single linkage clustering it finds the
minimum possible distance between points
belonging to two different clusters mean
linkage clustering it finds all possible
pairwise distances for points belonging
to two different clusters and then
calculates the average
centroid linkage clustering it finds the
centroid of each cluster and calculates
the distance between them
what is dendrogram
it is a tree diagram frequently used to
illustrate the arrangement of the
Clusters produced by hierarchical
clustering it shows the hierarchical
relationship between objects it is most
commonly created as an output of
hierarchical clustering the main use of
a dendrogram is to work out the best way
to allocate objects to clusters the
dendrogram also shows the hierarchical
clustering of five observations and the
relationship between each of them
hierarchical clustering example
let's understand hierarchical clustering
through an example in the given example
hierarchical clustering is used to find
the distances between the different
cities in kilometers
the following Matrix traces a
hierarchical clustering of distances in
miles between different cities the
method of clustering is single link here
as you can see from the given distance
Matrix the nearest pair of objects is t
o and MI
Mi and T.O are merged into a single
cluster called Mito as Mi column has
lower values than to column Mito
consists of Mi column values
Mito column has one index with zero
value this is because there is no
distance between cluster Mito and Mito
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
now the nearest pair of objects is n a
and RM these are combined into a single
cluster called narm to get a new
distance Matrix we compute the distance
from this new cluster to all other
clusters in the similar way the nearest
pair of objects is ba and narm these are
combined into a single cluster called ba
n a r m to get a new distance Matrix we
compute the distance from the new
cluster to all other clusters
similarly now the nearest pair of
objects is ba narm and f i these
combined into a single cluster called
b-a-n-a-r-m-f-i
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
finally we merge the last two clusters
this process is summarized by the
clustering diagram on the right and the
final distance Matrix on the left why
reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if I'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if I
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer machine learning
aren't able to do that very well there's
a couple of them that can be used or
integrated to see how it goes is what
we're talking about with reinforcement
learning so what is reinforcement
learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains the
model to return an Optimum solution for
a problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important as we're
looking for Unique Solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different systems or different model
we have supervised versus unsupervised
versus reinforcement learning and with
the supervised learning that is probably
the most controlled environment we have
a lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all this information you
already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so your supervised
learning you already know that the
outcome for tomorrow for you know going
back a week you're looking at stock you
can already have like the graph of what
the next day looks like so you have an
answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves Problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and the answer
provide learning is really interesting
because it's now taking part in many
other models they start with an you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data is used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
uh so you can look at this and you can
think some of these things go with each
other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this
um when you start getting into those
there's some really cool images that
come up of what unsupervised learning is
how it can pick out say the area of a
donut one model will see the area of the
donut and the other one will divide it
into three sections based on its
location versus what's next to it so
there's a lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market in machine learning or
growing Market is very it's very infant
stage as far as how it works and what
it's going to be capable of the machine
learns from its environment using
rewards and errors used to solve reward
based problems no predefined data is
used no supervision follows Trail and
error problem solving approach so again
we have a random at first you start with
a random I try this it works and this is
my reward doesn't work very well maybe
or maybe it doesn't even get you what
you're trying to get it to do and you
get your reward back and then it looks
at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years so these are
really good to know we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual entity that has however
you're doing it with using a neural
network or a
Q table or whatever combination thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here I guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output and then you have your action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model and it picks one
action and you can see here that's
picked three different routes to get to
the chest of diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those Mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on but then you have your current
position where are you on that game
board what's around that what's around
you if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard where it is in the yard and
what it can see what input it has in
that location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if didn't do as good trying
to maximize the reward and have the best
reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
State this is part of the model what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent one of
the reasons they separate policy as its
own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options and then the
policy well how am I going to pick the
best based on those predictions I'm
going to guess at different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works let's go ahead and take a look at
a reinforcement learning example and
just in looking at this we're going to
take a look consider what a dog that we
want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever and
then your environment is going to be the
whole house or whatever it is or where
you're training them and then you have
an action we want to teach the dog to
fetch
so action equals fetching and then we
have a little biscuit so we can get the
dog to perform various actions by
offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself so you have ba
you know so we started off with fetching
it goes oh I get a biscuit for that it
tries something else you get a handshake
or begging or something like that and
goes oh this is also reward based and so
it kind of explores things to find out
what will bring it is biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes is it looks for different
rewards how do I find can I try
different things and find a reward that
works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explore its environment uh this
quality of model is called exploration
so there's a little Randomness going on
in Exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
markov's decision process is a
reinforcement learning policy used to
map a current state to an action where
the agent continuously interacts with
the environment to produce new Solutions
and receive rewards and you'll see
here's all of our different uh
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state or agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent
uh the agent then looks at this state or
it looks at the reward usually um first
and it says okay I got rewarded for
whatever I just did or it didn't get
rewarded and it looks at the state and
then it comes back and if you remember
from policy the policy comes in and then
we have a reward the policy is that part
that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey what's a good action that will
probably be similar to what I did or
sometimes are completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using
um pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works you can
see your environment sends it says hey
this is what the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says I'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was and
then it has a new state and a new reward
that goes back to the agent so in the
diagram shown we need to find the
shortest path between node A and D each
path has a reward associated with it and
the path with a maximum reward is what
we want to choose
the node ABCD denote the nodes to travel
from node A to B is an action reward is
the cost of each path and policy is each
path taken
and you can see here a can go to B
or a can go to C right off the bat or it
can go right to D and if explored all
three of these you would find that a
going to D was a zero reward a going to
C and D would generate a different
reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in a tic-tac-toe game but
you can see here once it's gone through
these and it's explored it's going to
find the ACD is the best reward it gets
a full 30 points for it
and computer programming an algorithm is
a set of well-defined instruction to
solve a particular problem it takes a
bunch of information sources and deliver
the ideal result most of us must be
using a Snapchat to apply filters on
your faces while making videos or
capturing photographs but do you know
how does Snapchat recognize your face
while capturing videos or photographs
and put filters on it even if there are
multiple faces it applies filter on
every face accurately this became
possible with the help of basic
cognition technique which uses machine
learning algorithms to detect phases and
apply required filters on them so this
is the basic idea of how an algorithms
work let's move ahead in this video and
we will now discuss how an algorithm
work in machine learning but before that
let's go through what is machine
learning
machine learning is the subpart of
artificial intelligence the art of
making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and make
predictions based on experience as we
saw in previous example when the data
that is how far is the nearest fuel
station comes in the machine or in our
case CD immediately start analyzing data
and machine accurately makes prediction
and decision based on given data now
that we have an understanding of what
machine learning is let's move forward
and discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified into
supervised learning unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning there
are two sort of problems in supervised
learning classification and regression
certain types of machine learning
algorithms fall under the
classifications are decision algorithm
KN algorithm logistic algorithms name
base algorithm support Vector machine
algorithm svm however in regression
types of machine learning algorithms are
linear regression regression trees
non-linear regression and Bayesian
linear regression
you know talking about unsupervised
learning there are two sorts of problems
in unsupervised learning clustering and
Association algorithms that fall under
clustering problems include k-means
clustering algorithms principal
component analysis algorithms however
algorithms that fall under Association
problem are a priority algorithms FP
growth algorithms and reinforcement
learning there are two types positive
reinforcement negative reinforcement
reinforcement learning algorithms are
mainly used in AI applications and
gaming applications
there are certain types of problems
which force under reinforcement learning
are Q learning State action reward State
action sarsa algorithms if you neural
network and Markov decision process
after discussing what machine learning
is and its side let's move forward to
see how algorithm work in machine
learning
everyone knows the algorithm is a
step-by-step process to approach a
particular problem there are numerous
examples of algorithm from figuring out
sets of number to finding routes through
maps to showing data on a screen let's
understand this by using an example
every algorithm is built on inputs and
outputs Google search algorithm is no
different the input is the search field
and the output is the page of its result
that appears when you enter a particular
phrase or keyword also known as serp or
search engine result page
Google has a search algorithm so it can
sort results from various websites and
provides the users the best result
when you start a search you will see the
search box will attempt to guess what
you are looking for in order to better
understand what the user is looking for
the algorithm is trying to gather as
many as suggestions from them as
possible
the results from the search field that
best matches the query will be ranked
the choose fit website will Rank and in
what position using more than 200
ranking variables now let's take an
example of coding program and see how
the algorithm works
here we will use a case of computer
program wherein we want to print the
multiplication table of any number let's
take two the algorithm start here and
then it assign a value to a variable the
variable I is having an initial value of
1. the system will read the number the
number in case is 2. now the system has
a condition a condition can now either
be true or false if the value of I
reaches 11 then the loop will end
otherwise value of I will multiply by
the number the initial value of I is 1
so for the first time the system output
will be 2. now value of I will be
increased by 1. according to the loop
condition
the system will then move back and check
for the condition again the new value of
I is 2. which is still less than 11 the
system will again print 2 into Y which
is 2 into 2 on this screen the new
output result will be 4. the system will
keep following the same procedure
repeatedly until the value of I becomes
11. once the value of I becomes 11 then
only the algorithm will terminate after
discussing how an algorithm work let's
move forward and see some popular
machine learning algorithms
some popular machine learning algorithms
are
first one is linear regression algorithm
second one is logistic regression
algorithm
and the third one is decision tree
and the fourth one is support Vector
machine algorithm svm
and the fifth one is KNN K nearest
neighbor algorithms and the sixth one is
K means clustering algorithms the and
the seventh one is random Forest
algorithms and the last but not the
least algorithm is a priority algorithms
let's go through them in detail one by
one
linear depression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
show the linear connection between the
dependent and independent factors
the equation of line is y equals to MX
plus b here y stand for this response
variable or a dependent variable whereas
X is for the Predator variable or an
independent variable it attempts best to
fit line between the dependent and
independent variables and this best bit
line is known as line of regression or
regression line
let's take a real application example in
predicting consumer Behavior businesses
use the linear regression to forecast
things like how much a client is likely
to spend
things like targeted marketing and
product development May benefit from
this
Walmart for instance use linear
regression to forecast which good would
be in high demand Across the Nation
moving forward let's see types of linear
regression
there are two types of linear regression
algorithm
the first one is simple linear
regression and the second one is
multiple linear regression
in simple linear regression if an
independent variable is utilized to
forecast the worth of a mathematical
dependent variable then at that point
such a linear regression algorithm is
called Simple linear regression the
equation of line will be y equals to a0
plus a 1 X
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variables
declines on the Y and the independent
variable on the X then such a
relationship is known as negative linear
relationship the line of equation will
be minus of a 0 plus a 1 X
moving forward let's see logistic linear
regression
logistic regression is this supervised
machine learning algorithm which
utilized to anticipate all the
categorical factors or discrete values
it could be very well used for the
grouping issues in machine learning and
the result of the logistic regression
can be either yes or no 0 or 1 men or
women and so on it gives the values
which lies between 0 and 1. for example
a credit card business is interested in
knowing whether the transaction amount
and the credit score have an impact on
the probability that a particular
transaction would be fraudulent the
business can use logistic redirection to
determine how these two Predator values
can relate the probability that a
transaction is fraudulent
this response variable in the model has
two possible outcomes
first one is the transaction is
shortland and the second one is the
transaction is not fault line
in logistic regression rather than
fitting a regression line we fit an S
form logistic capability which predicts
two greatest value 0 or 1. the logistic
regression equation can be calculated
from linear regression equation the
steps to get logistic regression
equations are the equation of straight
line can be written as y equals to b0
plus B1 X1 plus b 2 x 2 till b n x n in
logistic regression y can be between 0
and 1 only so for that let's divide the
above equation by 1 minus y then the
equation will be y upon 1 minus y that
is 0 for y 0 and Infinity for y equals
to 1 but range between minus infinity to
plus infinity then we have to take the
logarithm of equation and now it will
become log of Y upon 1 minus y equals to
b0 plus b 1 x 1 plus b 2 x 2 so on till
b n x n let's move forward and see types
of logistic regression
there are three types of logistic
regression that can be classified first
one is binomial in binomial logistic
regression there can be only two
possible types of dependent variables
like yes or no password man woman and
many more and the second one is
multinomial in multinomial logistic
regression there can be three or more
possible unordered ways of dependent
variable such as horse cow and sheep and
the last one is ordinal inordinary
logistic regression there can be three
or more possible ordered ways of
dependent variable such as small medium
or large moving forward let's see
decision trees in detail
a decision tree is a tree structured
classifier that could be used for
classification and regression a decision
tree is a tree in which each non-leaf
node is assigned to an attribute
additionally each are contained one of
the available values for its parent node
which is associated with each Leaf node
that is the node from where the arc is
directed let's see some decision tree
terminology
first one is root that contains the
entire data set the next one is node a
test for the data of a certain attribute
and the third one is branch which
connect the node to internal node or the
internal node to Leaf node and the
fourth one is leaf node the terminal
node that predicts the outcome let's
move forward and see decision tree
algorithms the first one is select the
best attribute to use the current node
in the tree the second one is for each
possible values select the attributes
the third one is partition the examples
using the possible values of this
attribute and assign these disjoint
subset or the example to the appropriate
child node recursively generate each
child node until ideally all examples
for a node have the same label like
class moving forward let's understand
this recently for building a decision
tree Step One is Select an attribute
then split the data into its children in
a tree continue splitting with available
attributes
and keep splitting until late node are
pure like only one class remains a
maximum depth is a performance metric is
achieved let's move forward and see svm
algorithm support Vector machine
algorithms
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for both information
classification and regression
it is regularly utilized for the
grouping issues we can involve it in
different life care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or sad
look Arrangements we can involve it in
filters if we make specific Loops it
would add the particular filter
according to the expression the scope of
articulation lies between happy and sad
support Vector machine helps them to
recognize and return characters use
widely like checks continue to which a
significant part of the majority of
non-cash transaction and are frequently
written by the pupil
the current check processing system in
many developing nations involves a bank
employee to read and manually enter the
information in a check while also
verifying the data like signature and
date
a handwritten text recognition system
can reduce expenses and labor hours
because a bank must handle several
checks each day
moving forward let's see the algorithm
of svm
the objective of support Vector machine
is to make the best line or Choice limit
that can isolate and dimensional space
into classes so we can undoubtedly put
the new data of interest in the right
category later on this batch decision
boundary is known as a hyperplate let's
move forward and see types of support
Vector machine support Vector machine
can be of two types first one is linear
svm second one is non-linear SPM let's
move forward and see linear sphere
linear svm is utilized for linearly
detachable information
which implies if a data set can be
ordered into two classes by utilizes a
straight line then such information are
named linearly separable information and
a classifier is utilized called linear
SPM classifier moving forward let's see
non-linear svm
non-linear SPM is utilized for
non-dietly isolated information and that
implies in the event that a data set
can't be categorized by utilizing a
straight line
such information is named non-directed
information
and the classifier utilize is called a
non-linear SPM classifier moving forward
let's see k n algorithm in detail
Canon is a supervised learning technique
Canon classifies new data into our
targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points and
also we use for the regression problems
it is an instance based learning
algorithm and a bit lazy learning
algorithm k n calculation stores every
one of its accessible information and
orders another information Point based
on the likeliness this means that when
new data information appears it usually
tends to the successfully categorized
into a good suit classes using the k n
algorithm let's imagine we have an image
of animal that resembles a cow or Ox
however here we are not sure if it is a
cow or Ox as k n method is based on a
likeness Matrix it will identify the
properties of new data that are related
to the image of cow or ox
and based on those quality it will
classify the data is belonging to either
cow or Ox group
moving forward let's see how does k n
work
the steps to implement k n algorithms
are step one decide on the neighbor's K
numbers Step 2 calculate the euclidean
distance between K Neighbors in step 2.
third one is based on the determined
nuclear distance select the K closest
neighbors step 4 is count the numbers of
data points in each category between
these scannables step 5 assign the fresh
data points in the category where the
highest neighbors count and then k n
model is ready
Let's see we need to add a new data
point to the vital category at first we
will decide on the numbers of neighbors
therefore we will pick k equals to 5.
then the euclidean distance between the
data points and then can be determined
the distance between two points known as
the euclidean distance can be determined
by under root of X2 minus X when the
whole square plus Y2 minus y 1 whole
Square
then we determine the closest neighbors
by calculating the equivalent distance
there are three closest Neighbors in
category a and two closest neighbor in
category B
this new data point Must Fall with
category a because as we can see its
three closest neighbors are also from
group a after understanding k n
algorithm let's move forward and see
k-means algorithms in detail
the K means in the cluster falls under
that is announced supervised learning
algorithm it is used to address machine
learning clustering problems and utilize
to tackle the grouping issues in machine
learning
hit permits us to punch the information
into various Gatherings it is a helpful
method for finding the classification of
groups in the unlabeled data set without
the requirement of any training this
k-means algorithm groups the data into
similar classes let's see some
application of k-means clustering let's
see some applications of k-means
clustering diagnostic system the medical
profession uses k-means casting in
creating smarter medical decision
support system especially in the
treatment of lever alignments the second
one is search engines clustering forms a
backbone of search engine when a search
engine is performed the search result
need to be grouped and the search
engines very open use clustering to do
this moving forward let's see how
k-means algorithm works
the steps to implement k-means
algorithms are Step 1 select the number
key to set the number of clusters Step 2
select a random K points or centroid
step 3 assign each data point the
closest centroid data forms to
predefined K cluster step 4 determine
the variance and a certain new Gravity
points for each cluster step 5 repeat
the third step this means reallocating
each data point to the new closest
centroid cluster step 6 if I
reassignment occurs go to step 4
otherwise go to exit step 7 the model is
ready to use
so now we have a clear understanding of
how k-means algorithm work let's move
forward to see the graphical
representation of k-means algorithm
consider that there are two variables M1
and M2 this is a scatter plot of these
two variables along the X and Y axis we
should accept the number of k o punches
that is k equals to 2 to recognize the
data set and to place them into various
groups it implies here we will attempt
to Bunch these data set into two unique
groups people really want to pick an
irregular key point or centroid to frame
this group
these centroids can be either the focus
of the data set or some of other points
thus here we are choosing under two
points as cables which are not the piece
of our data set
we will assign every data of interest in
this scatter plot to the nearest K point
or centroid
we will register it by applying some
math that we consider to find the
distance between two points that is
euclidean distance thus we will draw a
median between both the centroids from
the graph the laptop of the line are
close points to the right and the K1
centroid green is near the orange
centroid we should variety them as green
and orange for Clear representation as
the need might arise to track down the
nearest group we will repeat the cycle
by picking another centroid
to pick the new centroid we will figure
out the center point of gravity of the
centroid and will track down new
centroids then we will reassign every
piece of information to highlight new
centroid for this we will repeat a
similar course of tracking down a middle
line the middle will be like as seen in
the picture one orange point is on the
left half of the line and two green
points are on the right thus these three
points will be appointed to the new
centroids as reassignment has occurred
we will again go to step 4 tracking down
new centroids or k points we will repeat
the cycle by tracking down the center
point of gravity of centroid so the new
centroids will be displayed as like this
we now have new centroid so once more
defined the middle boundary and reassign
the data of Interest by this graph there
are no unique pieces of information on
one of the other side of the line
implying our model is shaped by the
previous graph there are no unique
pieces of information on one or the
other line implying our model is shaped
as our k-means model is ready and the
two plus groups will be displayed as
like these now we have a clear
understanding of how k-means clustering
algorithm works now let's move forward
to understand random Forest algorithm
random Forest is an adaptable simple to
utilize machine learning algorithm that
produces even without the hyper boundary
tuning and extraordinary outcome more
often than not
it is likewise quite possibly the most
utilized algorithm because of its
effortness and variety like its tend to
be utilized for both grouping and
classification tasks
random 4S is a classifier that contains
various Choice trees on different
subsets of the given data set and takes
the normal to work on the present
exactness of the data set instead of
depending on the choice tree the random
Forest takes the forecast from history
and in light of the larger part of
boards of expectation it predicts the
final result
now let's move forward and see how does
random Forest work
we should see the random forest in order
since the arrangement is now and again
thought to be the structured block of
machine learning this is what a random
Forest would look like with two trees
the random Forest has a similar
hypermeter to their decision tree or a
paging classifier luckily there is a
compelling reason need to consolidate a
decision trade with a badging classifier
since you can undoubtedly utilize the
classified classes of random courage
with random Forest you can likewise
manage tasks using the algorithm
regression random forests add extra
habitness to the model while deploying
the trees rather than looking for the
main element while parting a node
it looks to the best component among an
irregular subset of highlights these
outcomes in a wide variety often result
in a superior model
subsequently in a random Forest just a
random subset of the element is thought
about the algorithms you might make
trees more random by involving random
edges for each component instead of
looking for the most ideal limits like a
typical Choice tree does
let's move forward and see some
application of random Forest algorithms
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient history and
safety in banking random Forest is used
to identify clients who are more likely
to pay back their debts on schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of Bank
Services even fraud detection uses it
the revenue of algorithms indeed
random Forest is a tool used by stock
Trader to forecast future stock Behavior
retail businesses utilize it to make
product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random Forex can be
used in healthcare industry to examine a
patient medical history and detect
disorders random Forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical expert to determine
the idle mix of ingredients in treatment
or to forecast drug sensitivity by
seeing application of random Forest
algorithm let's move forward and see
some difference between decision trees
and random Forest
let's see the difference between random
forest and decision tree the first one
is
while building a random Forest the
number of rows is selected randomly
in decision trees it builds several
decision trees and find out the output
the second one is it combines two or
more decision trees together in decision
trees whereas the decision is a
collection of variables or data sets or
attributes the third one is it gives
accurate results whereas it gets less
accurate results the fourth one is by
using random Forest it reduces the
chance of overlifting whereas decision
trees it has the possibility of
overlifting the fifth one is random
Forest is more complicated to
interpreters whereas the decision tree
is simple it is easy to read and
understand
after seeing what is random Forest how
it works let's move forward to see a
primary algorithm in detail
the Apparently algorithm utilize
standard item sets to create affiliation
rules and is intended to chip away the
information basis containing exchanges
with the assistance of these application
rules it decide how firmly or feebly two
objects are associated
this algorithm utilize a breakfast
search and history to work out the items
at Association effectively
it is the iterative interaction for
finding out the successive item set from
the huge data set
let's move forward and see steps for a
priority algorithms the steps for a
priority algorithms are Step One is
establish minimal support and confidence
for item set in the transactional
database the second one is take all
transaction supports with a greater
support value the minimum or chosen
support value in Step 2 the third one is
track down all the rules in these
subsets with confidence value greater
than the threshold value the fourth one
is arrange the rules to lower the lift
at last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of a priority algorithm
the advantages of a priority algorithms
are easy to understand an algorithm and
the second one is the join and prune
steps of the algorithms can be easily
implemented on the large data set the
disadvantages of a priority algorithms
are they are priority algorithms work
slowly as compared to the other
algorithm and the second one is the
apprary algorithms times and space
complexity are o of 2D which is very low
compared to the other ones machine
learning has improved our lives in a
number of wonderful ways today let's
talk about some of these I'm Rahul from
Simply learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistance Google Assistant Alexa
Cortana and Siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record whatever
you're saying send it over to a server
which is usually in a cloud decode it
with the help of machine learning and
neural networks and then provide you
with an output so if you ever notice
that these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say I
wanted to travel from Buckingham Palace
to Lord's cricket ground the first thing
I would probably do is to get on Google
Maps so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there yellow indicate that they
are slightly congested and red means
they are heavily congested so let's look
at the map a different version of the
same map and here as I told you before
red means heavily congested yellow means
slow moving and blue means clear
so how exactly is Google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from Google
Maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
Bing Maps maps.me and here we go next up
we have social media personalization so
say I want to buy a drone and I'm on
Amazon and I want to buy a DJI mavic Pro
the thing is it's close to one lap so I
don't want to buy it right now but the
next time I'm on Facebook I'll see an
advertisement for the product next time
I'm on YouTube I'll see an advertisement
even on Instagram I'll see an
advertisement so here with the help of
machine learning Google has understood
that I'm interested in this particular
product hence it's targeting me with
these advertisements this is also with
the help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
Gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so Gmail hasn't entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data Gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that Gmail uses is content
filters header filters General Blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward and neural networks
are that the outputs are converted into
hash values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values Stock Market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to Stock
Market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict data when there are time lags
the one known size and duration now this
is used to predict stock market trends
assist to Medical Technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3D models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and ischemic stock lesions they
can also be used in fetal Imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug Discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see Billboards and science that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequential sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other
a collection of python bindings called
opencv
python was created to address issue with
the computer vision
pythony's general purpose programming
language created by gyoto Von Rasam that
quickly gained popularity largely due to
its ease of use and readable code the
programmer can express Concept in less
code without sacrificing readability
numpy a highly efficient library for
numerical operation with a Matlab like
syntax is used by opencv python
numpy arrays are translated into and out
of all opencv array forms additionally
this make it simpler to interact with
other numpy using libraries like scipy
and matplotlib after understanding what
is opencv let's move forward and see
what phase detection is so what is Phase
detection
phase detection also known as facial
detection is a computer technology that
uses artificial intelligence to find and
recognize human faces in digital
photographs
Fair detection technology can be enabled
real-time surveillance and tracking of
people in various Industries such as
security Biometrics law enforcement
entertainment and personal safety
from basic computer vision method to
developments in machine learning to
increasingly use complex artificial
neural network and related Technologies
phase detection has advanced leading or
to ongoing performance increases
it now serves as the foundation from
some crucial applications such as face
tracking phase analysis face recognition
the application ability to perform
sequential tasks subsequently impacts
the phase Direction
so dear learner if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give a chance to Simply land
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or give your answer
in the chat section so I can see if the
answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which of the
following function is a built-in
function in Python
factorial
print
seed
sqrt
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section please do
let me know your answers
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python factorial
print seed sqrt let us know your answer
in the comment section below
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this session
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
30 seconds more factorial print seed
sqrt
please let me know your answer in the
comment section below
20 seconds remaining
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
10 seconds more
please let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the current response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to create phase detection using
opencv python
so first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a phase
detection system
so first let me rename this
paste
Direction
first we will import import
CV2
press enter then import another Library
import numpy
as NP
and the third one is Major One Import
face
recognition
[Music]
as
fr
then press enter
so CV means capturing video
the CV2 function is an opencv can read
video video capture by using pass 0
function parameter we can access our
webcam we may pass as rtsp URL in the
function parameter to capture the CCTV
footage
which is quite helpful for video
analysis
and another one is numpy numpy is a
python Library used for working with
arrays it also has function for working
in the domain of linear algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
you can use it freely numpy stands for
numerical python
and the third one is Phase recognition
phase recognition and manipulation using
python or the command line the easiest
facial recognition library in the world
built using Cutting Edge face
recognition technology from dlib
developed using deep learning
so moving forwards let's import our
video capture device so for that we have
to write a video
underscore capture this is our variable
name
equals to
CV2 Dot
video
capture
and we have to pass here zero
then press enter
okay here V
should be capital
so the video capture function from
opencv is used to interact with the
cameras what we can do is video can be
read shown and saved display the image
that the camera captured
so moving forward let me import my image
for the further detection process okay
so
image equals to
FR dot load
underscore image
underscore file
then
image name or image path boy
dot jpg
press enter
using load image file we can import
image file to our detection system so
moving forward let's set encoding for
the image okay so I will write here
image underscore phase underscore
encoding
equals to
FR Dot
face
encodings
and image
than zero
press enter
yeah so face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measure to represent
the phase similar encoding would be
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so moving forward let's do let me write
first
I will write here known
encodings
equals to
image
phase
coding
okay
then press enter
then known
phase
names
equals to
then here I have to put my name so I
will write
Bank
okay then press enter
so what I did is I assigned known page
encodings to my image face encoding so
what will happen if image matches to my
face then it will print my name and for
the rest we will add name unknown okay
so let me add the function now for phase
detection system
so let me write the full code for it
first then I will explain you line wise
okay
so just stay tuned with me
I will write here
so I will add while
okay true
okay so r e t comma frame I will explain
you line wise line don't worry equals to
then video
capture
dot read
and RGB
underscore frame
was to
frame
then colon
comma then again colon comma then two
colon
then minus 1.
okay
yeah
so here I will write FC underscore
locations
equals to FR dot face
underscore locations
RGB
underscore frame
right here FC FC is for basically face
encodings
plus two fr
dot face
underscore encodings
and RGB
underscore frame
comma FC underscore
locations
okay
so for
top
comma right comma
bottom
left
okay then I have to write a face
the score encoding
comma face underscore encoding this is
that was encodings this is encoding
okay so before that I will write here
Okay so
I have to write here encoding
in zip
okay then here I have to write
FC underscore
locations locations
okay
then comma then face encodings
colon
then press enter
so here I have to write matches
yeah
matches equals to FR dot compare
and faces
then known
the score phase
score encodings
comma phase underscore encoding
okay
so
it so what if
the image will not match so I have to
give the name equals to
unknown
then we will write face distances
plus 2
FR dot phase
underscore distances
underscore encodings
comma
paste
School encoding
then I will write match underscore index
equals to NP Dot
AR
G min
okay then I will write here FC
underscore distances
yeah
then moving forward
I have light if
matches
then match underscore
index
okay then colon
then name
equals to
known underscore phase
underscore names
then
match underscore index
and I have to write here CV2
Dot
rectangle
and frame
comma
comma top
comma right
to give another bracket here
comma
bottom
that comma
0 comma 0 comma 255
again comma then 2 for the Border
so then CV2 dot rectangle
yeah
oh Mom then again
left comma
bottom
then minus
35.
okay
so then I will write
comma bottom
then again
0 comma 0 comma 255
then CV2 dot f i l l e d field
okay
F should be capital
yeah
so then we will set font equals to
CV2
Dot
font
okay
font
the score
underscore
simplex
okay
so then I have to write here
CV2
dot put
text
name
comma name
comma
left
six
comma bottom
minus six
okay then comma point
comma
1.0 then
again one comma then we have to set
location like 255
comma 255
comma 255
then comma
1.
okay
and here I have to write CV2
dot image show I am show
then like
simply learn
is detection
comma frame
foreign
CV2 Dot
weight key
is 1
and
like 0 x
f
the capital f f equals to equals to
ORD then
quit
and here I will write break
I will write video
underscore capture
dot release
TV2
dot destroy
all
windows
okay yeah
so let me explain you
so in general rad is a Boolean value
that indicates whether or not there was
a even a return each frame that is
written is at this same frame if there
is no frame you will receive none rather
than an error
in opencv reading and writing videos and
reading and writing images are quite
similar a video is nothing more than a
collection of pictures often known as
frames
so to draw a rectangle around the face
that was discovered we utilize the
opencv rectangle the rectangle function
we can draw the rectangle by using the
points or Corners position that the
phase location
and
yes encoding this a face encoding this
one
so a face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measures to represent
the phase similar encoding what we
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different into
images of two distinct people
so this there is a use compare phase
so compare phase is used to compare my
face to uploaded image one okay if it
matches it will print my name otherwise
we have given a known here
so the numpy argr
this one
but it went this numpy ARG min
so the number ARG Min method delivers
the indexes of the arrays minimum
element along each axis return an array
of array indices with the same shape of
the array
so this font that is yeah
simplex
is normal size of sans serif font okay
so put text put text is used to put the
text on the frame like my name or
unknown
so in order to display an image in a
window we use the IM show this one
this I am sure function
okay so the window adjust itself to the
size of image parameters window name a
string that identifies the window in
which the displayed image will appear
okay
so until a key is pressed wait key zero
this one okay so until a key is pressed
wait key 0 will will keep the window
open it is suitable for image display
and wait key one
I write here wait key one
so wait key one will show a frame for
one Ms before closing the display on its
own
so after the script has ended users can
close or remove all the windows use the
python
like using destroy all function function
okay you would use the function if you
wanted to close a window while it was
open in numerous windows at once
so let's see our phase detection system
is working or not so let me close this
person on your screen first okay so let
me close this first
let me run this
now so here you can see this pop-up and
I will open so here you can see my name
is correctly printing
okay
so
like I have uploaded my image it's
directing correctly okay
so like what if I show uh one more image
so here you can see this is my card
so it is
detecting properly
yeah
so what if I will show like another guy
image so from my mobile
so here you can see
it is spring unknown in
Messi's photo
yeah
so what if if I will write here like uh
one of the
other image this random.jpg then it
should print unknown for me also okay
then I will run it again
okay it's working
has come
so here you can see it is now printing
unknown because like I have uploaded
that another random image here so it is
importing
okay so it is printing unknown here
so here you can see like it's spinning
unknown for me also
next to speech is an API cloud service
that enables you to turn return text
into real sounding audio in a range of
languages and voices
by connecting with people in their own
language you can give your business a
voice an enhanced customer experience
and engagement
increasingly accessibility of users of
diverse abilities offering audio
alternatives to prevent driving while
distracted or automating customer
service interaction to reduce hold items
so let's move to our programming part to
create a text to speech converter
application using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
to open Jupiter notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open new python file
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in creating UI and to convert text to
speech so the first one is
import
sorry import
EK enter
as PK
so TK enter is also known as TK
interface the default python interface
for TCL TK GUI toolkit is the TK enter
package or ticker interface
majority of Unix System including Mac OS
as well as Windows machine support TK
and TK in turn TK enter which is part of
all common python distribution is a
binding legal method for creating
graphical user interface GUI in Python
it is the only framework included in the
python standard library in fact
so the next one is
first we will write here
import
sorry
from
TK enter
port
so from
TK enter
port
I
I love
to file dialog TK enter provides a
number of built-in methods and class
Library function to create application
components and user actionable elements
one of the TK enter modules called file
dialog offers classes and Library
functions for making windows for
selecting files and dictionaries
when you need to request that a user
browser file or directory on the system
you can use file dialog
so the next one is
from
EK enter
Dot ttk
import
combo box
combo box combines an entry field and a
list box
one of the TK interviews it has down
arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it dates consumer and
choosing from the list of available
options a pop-up of a scrolling list box
is displayed down the entry field when
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the entry field only when option from
the list box is selected will the select
option be shown in the enter field
this one is
it is one of the major One Import
Ty
t x
3
okay
so a python text to speech conversion
library is called pytt sx3
it is compatible with python 2 and 3 and
works offline unlike competing libraries
to obtain a reference to a pytx library
engine instance an application called
the pytic X3 init Factory method it is a
very user-friendly program that turns
type text to speech
is a P5 for windows program offers two
voices that the pytd sx3 module supports
a female voice and a male voice CTS
engines are supported by it Windows 7 I5
nssp for Mac OS e-speak is available on
all other platform
so the next one is
import
OS
so the OS module in Python has function
for adding and deleting folders
retrieving their contents changing the
directory locating the current directory
and more before you can communicate with
the underlying operating system you must
import the OS module
the next one is
from
gtts
import
gtts
from
play sound
port
a sound
so gdts python has a variety of apis
that can turn text into speech the
Google text to speech API often known as
gtts API is one of these apis gtts is a
simple to use program that turns enter
text into audio that can be saved as MP3
file
languages including English Hindi Tamil
French German Spanish and many more are
supported via gtts API
any one of the two accessible audio
speeds Rapid or slow may be used to
deliver the speech the voice of created
audio however cannot be changed as the
most recent version
so let me run this
so after importing major libraries let's
move forward and start creating user
interface
so I will write here import sorry
root equals to
t k
put dot
title
simply learn
to speech
converter
root Dot
geometry
I will give a thousand
580
plus 200 from y axis and
and
80 from Top
okay
root Dot decisable
will make it to like false
false
and again false
okay
then
dot configure
background should be PG equals to
use here hash
F7
AC
40
and
okay first I will explain this so here
TK stands for TK entered Library
every word in the string returned by the
title
method begins with an uppercase letter
like a title or a header the following
letter will be changed to uppercase if
the word contains a number or a symbol
one of the built-in methods in TK enter
is geometry which is used to specify
Dimension while TK enter widget windows
are mostly used to set the application
Windows Dimension length
the TK enter root Windows size can be
changed in accordance with the needs of
the user using the resizable this one
or we can forbid resizing of the TK
enter window in other words this
approach can be used to generate a
window with a defined size
Simple Text changes can be made to
labels using python TK interconfig
function two widgets are shown in the
example below
a label and a button when the button is
pressed a function that is attached to
the button execute the label config
method
you can give background color as per
your choice I've gave this orange
something
so let's run this and see the first look
of UI by writing here I will write here
root
Dot main Loop
I will run and all
okay
so this is how our UI looks like first
UI so I can't resize because I gave here
false
false
I can't resize it
so if I will write here
set of false I will write here true
and again
through here
so then I will run again
so now I can resize it
as per my choice
hey
yeah so I will write here
false
and again false
meant it
okay let's move forward and add some
logos in the application
I have already some PNG images on my
system you guys can use any picture of
your choice
I have some images here
images
so
you guys can use any picture of your
choice
so I will write here
simply
underscore logo
first two
photo
image
file
and path of file
e
zers
slash SLP
0 9 375
top
then
ETS
folder
yes folder
then
simply dot PNG
okay then I will set label
put
H equals to
simply image
empty logo sorry
and background
I can copy from here
Dot
place
plus two
880 and y axis should be
like I will give here uh five
okay
let's run this root
dot in Loop
okay there is something error
search file directory
a there is one now let me run this
yeah now you can see simply learn is
there I need a little bit down
so let me write again
[Music]
39
done it again
now it's looking good
yeah
the image object is returned by the
photo image function output it's that
easy to display a picture in Python
however the photo image class only
supports the GIF and PNG images
which is a concern JPEG and gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the container box where the text or
images can be placed is specified by the
label the widget is used to inform the
user or other widgets that are utilized
in the python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using a
number of different parameters
the root window
is where all the widgets are placed
this one the root window is this all the
widgets are placed
even TK enter application must include
precisely one increase of the class TK
which is an instance of app is a
subclass of frame
and app is in instance of app
by positioning them in a precise
location with the parent Widget the port
manager organize visits the option used
by the geometry manager our anchor
border mode height width real width x
and y anchor shows the location where
the widget is anchored
okay let's move forward and add logo
here instead of this add One logo here
so I will make it comment down
it yeah
so for that I will write logo
underscore image
equals to
photo
image
then file
will copy the paths from here
sit here
okay so let me change it to speech
dot PNG perfect so root
dot icon photo
false
for my logo
underscore image
put dot Main
oops
let me run this
yeah now you can see a logo here
so the image object is written by the
photo image function
output it is the easy to display a
picture in Python however the photo
image class only supports the GIF and
PGM which is a concern JPEG gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the title bar icon of the TK enter top
level window is set using the icon photo
but in order to set any image as a title
bar icon it must be an object of the
photo image class
so okay logo is added
this logo is added now we will make one
upper frame like this one upper frame
till here something like here
and we will add the heading and logo in
the frame
okay so let me do this let me make it as
a command
okay so I will write here upper frame
was to frame
and root
and background should be
you can use any color
so I will write here hashtag one four
a
seven DD
cool
then width should be
1500
yes I can give you 1200 is enough
and height should be
and 30 is fine
upper
m dot place
is equals to
zero and y equals to zero X and Y equals
to 0 y because we need at the top
so I will add one
picture there so picture
pursue
again photo
image
okay I can copy from
yeah same image I will add and label
and Venom but I'm adding here is like
upper
frame
image equals to
and background
should be the same
and Dot place
plus 2
150
and Y should be like I will give you a
20.
okay so let me run this
toot dot main to
run this run all
yeah
okay
okay here I have to write
y equals to 20.
and again
okay here what they should f is capital
hope now it will run properly
so the image is added here
yeah for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in a
user-friendly manner the frame widget is
a crucial it functions like a container
that organizes the positioning of other
widgets to arrange the layout and
provide these widgets the screen uses
rectangular regions
the root window is where all the widgets
are placed even TK enter application
must include precisely one instance of
the class TK
and the label is specifies the container
box where the text images can be placed
these widgets used to inform the user or
the other widgets that are utilized in
the python application
detects or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using
several different parameters
okay so logo is added and it's looking
great
so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding
any sort of code
so just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
I'm repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or if there are any question related to
python just put ads and comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
moving forward let's add a heading to
the application
so I will make it as a comment
first I will add
some
else below
better View
okay
so for that I will write here label
I have to head adding at the upper frame
so I will write here upper frame
could be
will give
X
2
each
converter
on should be
times
new
woman
a side should be 40 is enough I guess
and it should be bold
um
PG background color should be
I will add this one only so copy
paste it here
and foreground should be
White
and Dot place
at x equals to 250
and Y should be the same I guess I
should be
I will write 35
to 30.
let's run this root
dot main Loop
okay
done this
a it's like option front
okay this is font I
want sorry my bad
now it will work
I guess
yeah
so here you can see
text is added
so for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in use of
finding manner the frame widget is
crucial it function like a container
that organized positioning of the other
widgets
and the label is specified the container
box where the text or images can be
placed this widgets used to inform the
user of other widgets that are utilized
in the python application
and in TK enter there are three
different ways to specify a widget type
to put it simply use the string format
TK
direct phone format times 20 italic or
bold
Pawn family size styles is the structure
of the string where the style can be any
legal mashup of text style keywords
okay so heading is added now let's move
forward and make our text box for
writings text to it
so let me make first as a comment
okay
so we are creating text box so I will
write here text box
equals to
text
and root window so I will write here
root
Bond
so let me tell you first I will create a
text box like this or this
so font
equals to
Library
20.
and background should be black or white
okay let's do black first
let it take it quite only white
then relief is something
relief equals to
Groove
and wrap
reverse into
word or characters word
and border which should be
zero
okay
so text
box
dot place
should I place it x equals to
30.
comma y equals to
150
comma width
width
should be I will make it the longer ones
I will write here
940
then height
should be
180
so let's run this first root Dot
main Loop
let me run it
so yeah text box is created
hello guys
yeah
so textbook is created so the python
application uses the text widgets to
display text Data the single line text
box is implemented using the entry
widgets which TK enter offers the
multi-line style text is with a variety
of styles and characteristics is shown
using the text widget
instead of group you can use raised flat
Ridge and many more it is used to make
contact with within a text document with
using the rav features in TK enter we
may enclose the characters or words in
the TK widgets you can use word cares or
none are the available default values
for the wrap properties
the TK enter button BD option determines
the width or stroke of the Border that
encircles the button the width of the
Border round a button can be changed
using the BD
so by positioning them in a precise
location with the parameter
the put manager organized widgets the
option used by this geometry manager are
anchor border mode height weight
X and Y and many more
so our text box is created
you can write anything
now let's move forward and add some
combo box for selecting voice and speed
so first I will but I will do it I will
make it command
here
I will write
gender box
for male female
or equals to
combo
box
put
value
if the question
email
and font should be
should be
your phone should be r
or b o
t e then 12 cells should be 12. then
there is something called state
to ah
and then
with
12.
and
gender box
or place
so I will praise something here
something here like gender should be
here and speed should be here
so I will write here
equals to
40.
comma
y equals to
400.
and gender box
set
to mail
run it so root dot Main
to
let me run this
yeah so you can see male female yeah
this is combo box
so our combo box combines an entry field
and a list box one of the Tinker widgets
it has down arrow to choose from a menu
of possibilities it aids consumers in
choosing from the list of available
options
a pop-up of scrolling list box it
displayed down the entry field when the
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the enter field
only when an option from the list box is
selected with the selected option be
shown in the entry field
if I will select errors then it will
show female of male
so some variables supported by TK enter
can be used to change the values of TK
intervisits these variable operates as a
typical variable would
the values of these variable are set and
retrieved using the set and get methods
combobox combines a list box widgets and
an entry widget you can choose one value
from a group of values using a combo box
widget
you can also input a custom value in
addition
so set text is used to set the text in
the entry box in the python TK enter it
serves the purpose of an entering text
into the entry box when used as a
function
we will write a function and use as a
button to invoke it
so okay so it's look great
moving forward let's add one more combo
box for the speed one like Fast medium
and slow
so whatever I will do I will copy first
I will make it as a comment
so
first I will copy this and I will paste
it here
and I will write
feed box
again
hitbox
again
box
and I will set it to medium
them and that there will be three values
like
past
pm
and
slow
and I will place combo box
where should I place
will place it something like here I will
place it here
so
for that
I have to give X as
round 540
and Y should be same so
let me run this
and let's see
so yeah so it's looking fine function I
use here is same as the previous one
that we did for the gender one for this
one
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding
any code any sort of code so just put us
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the current solution I'm
repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or I can any query regarding
any code just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward let's add play button
to playing the return tags but before
that let's add something called select
voice and select speed label for these
two combo works for like select select
voice type and select speed
so let's add them quickly so I will
write here label
I am adding it to the root windows so I
will write here root
and text
equals to
select
voice type
and font
should be
times
woman
and size should be like 15 is enough I
guess it should be bold
comma
background color should be I will
here
copy
taste
yeah
foreground color should be
White
or place
equals to
40
and Y equals to
p 70.
okay let me copy this for the speed
up it and I will paste it here
I will write here speed
everything same
cut it and I will paste it here for the
running
so let me run this
select speed is there I don't know where
you select okay
okay I gave the same X values I guess
yeah
so here I have to write 540
let me run this again
yeah select voice mail female select
speed fast medium so
so the python application uses the text
widget to display the tax data the
single line textbook is implemented
using the entry widget which TK enter
offers
a foreground color of a button is set
using the TK enter button FG parameter
alternately the text color is on the
button
so it is looking cool now moving forward
let's add play button
somewhere here
so
I will write code for it
a
button
to I have one photo for it
Auto
let me copy the path
it here
and
satellite play
then play
scope vtn
first two
button
text
equal to X should be play
and there is something called compound
so left
image
pursue
a button
comma
background should be
White
and width
is 130
font
equals to
Ariel
d
old
border width
should be
2.1 e
c means centimeter
and there is something called command
equals to speak now
okay
let's go
etn Dot
place
X should be
435
why
should be
450
let me see root dot main to
come make it comment
okay okay
so this is a function
we haven't created function yet so I
will add it at the last
so till
see
this on a border with
okay okay w i dth
I hope now it will work
a TK enter
or in my bed
it's
yeah
so a python application can add buttons
by using the button widget these button
can show text or images that explain
what they are for when a button is
clicked
you can connect a function or method
that is called automatically using that
command so here compound determined the
best way to display text and an image or
the label cursor
to find how the mouse will look when it
over the widget
so the TK enter button BD option control
the Border width or stroke surrounding
the button
and some TK enter widgets let you use
command binding to link a callback
function to an even
it enters that you may specify a
function name in the widgets command
option
so that it will be called whenever an
event occurs on the widget
okay so our UI for the text to speech
converter application is created and it
is looking fabulous
so now let's add function for converting
the text to speech sound
let me write the code first and then I
will explain you line wise
okay
now we can write here
command equals to
signal
okay
so what I will do I will add a function
here
I will add function here
so let me write the code first then I
will explain you line-wise lies
so here I will write
ETS TTS is nothing just text to speech
variable
p y t t sx3
dot init
EF for function speak now
text equals to
text underscore box
dot get
1.0
LD and
gender equals to
Tender Box
okay dot get
and speed
equals to speed the score box
dot get
voices
equals to DTS dot get
property
prices
okay so there is one another function
set voice
if
gender
equals 2 equals to
male
ETS
Dot
that property
it should be capital
property
[Music]
yeah
voice
voice ID versus ID should be zero
dot ID
s
dot say
whatever written on text
TS
Dot
run
done and
I'm done for then else
PTS
dot that
property
voice
voices
button
dot ID
s dot say
text
and again TTS Dot
done
and
oh
here's I will for
I will write code for that speed if
text
and again if
speed plus 2 equals to
passed
and
ETS dot set
property
and rate
should be
250
at two voice
or else if
speed
also equals Zoom
yeah
so then
ETS dot set
property
and rate should be
150.
so that voice function will be called
else
TTS dots that
property
ets.set property and rate should be
it should be
60.
that voice
okay so function is created dot get dot
get get property find text okay
now let me run this
so let me explain you
pts is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytis X3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver the other engine instance
is returned if not a new engine is built
so speak now is a function which using
get function I am getting the values of
that text box voice I will show you it
so
from this
from this speak now I am getting the
value of text male and female then speed
and using the get property I am getting
the voices of male and female
in set voice what I did using ID 0 for
mail and assetting into the mail and
using id1 for female and assigning it to
the female
and in this lcf ladder I am setting
speed to a particular values using the
rate function and assigning them speed
in frames per second
so now let's see text-to-speech
conversations working or not
so what I will write here hello
coders
welcome
to
simply learn
so I will play
hello coders welcome to simplerlearn
hope you hear the sound
I repeat hope you heard the sound
and same thing I will from from female
okay object run and wait
okay there is an error
done and wait
I will write
let me run this again
hello simply learn
hello simple learn
and again with female voice
hello simple learn
I will write here hello simply learners
subscribe
to our
YouTube
Channel
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
then I will play it too fast
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
and I will put slow
hello simple learners
subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
what is this basic organization system
a program capacity to convert a spoken
language into written language is known
as a speech recognition system also
known as automatic seized recognition
computer voice recognition or speech to
text despite being sometimes confused
with voice recognition speech
recognition focus on converting speech
form a verbal to a text format whereas
voice recognition only aims to
distinguish the voice of a certain
person
voice and speech recognition are two
distance Technologies and they shouldn't
be confused
to recognize word in spoken language
speech recognition is used voice
recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their voice
so after knowing what is this speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does speech recognition
system work
PC cognition in Python works with
algorithm that perform linguistic and
acoustic modeling acoustic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our space
to get the more significant part of
speech as words and sentences speech
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy
with the help of microphone it then
converts the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text
it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyze the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio
all of this is done using natural
language processing NLP and neural
networks
hidden Markov models can be used to find
temporal patterns in speech and improve
accuracy so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
so the question is
which of the following is the correct
extension for the python file
I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C Dot py and option D dot p
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so I'm starting a timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section do let me
know your answers please I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
this live session exciting
so I am starting the timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
37 seconds remaining
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C dot py option D dot p
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
a currently asked that everyone take
part in this to make the live session
exciting
you have 15 seconds remaining
10 seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
three two one after that allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct or response will receive as
response and those Who provided the
incurrent response will receive one
okay so now let's move to our
programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prompt to write a
command to open jupyter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating speech
recognition system
so here we will write
first let me remain rename this
speech peacock
so first I will import import
teach
underscore
recognition
and second import
s x three
press enter
so the incredibly attention repeat the
incredibly extensible speech recognition
Library serves as a wrapper for a number
of well-known speech apis
the speech recognition Library includes
default API key for one of these the
Google web speech API hard coded that
implies that you can start moving
without needing to register for a
service
and python project would benefit greatly
from using the speech recognition
package due to its versatility and
usability
and then pyts X3 a python text to speech
conversion library is called pyts X3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyts X3 engine instance
an application calls the pyts X3 init
it is very user-friendly program that
turns type text to into speech
so moving forward let's write code for
actual speech recognition system
so here I will write
Sr
equals to speech
underscore
recognition
Dot
recognizer
R must be Capital here
that I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition
dot microphone
s
ource
two
then colon
yeah
here
I will write print
right here okay silence
please
then I will write here Sr dot adjust
underscore for underscore
ambient
underscore noise
then source 2 comma duration
equals to 2.
okay
then enter
then I will print something like
now
please
something like that
then I will write here audio
audio to
equals to Sr Dot listen
source
2.
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
Dot
recognize
okay
underscore
Google
audio
2.
then here I have to print the small
letters
in lower case so I will write here text
equals to text
dot lower
just
then here I will write print
it you say
Plus
text
everything look great
so a recognizer is a machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can then use a speech recognition in
Python to convert the spoken words into
text make a query or a give a reply you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words
like every time they recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or saying
this recognize Google
a function on the recognizer class
which you have now developed will be
used to query the Google web speech API
and convert spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
python built-in function lower is mostly
used to handle strings
the lower method converts each Capital
character in The provided string to
lowercase before returning the lower
caste string hit accept no arguments it
returned to the original text if the
supplied string has no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah
Renault
hello how are you doing
you can see hello how are you doing
printed
so let me try another one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
on YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is printed
so a speech to text is working fine
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
questions just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
now moving forward what if you want that
system will write what we are saying and
speak that too
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want the system will
write what we are saying and speak that
too
so for that we will write a small line
of code
so first we will do
we will create one here
like we will insert cell below we will
write a function here so d f
speak now
command
colon then voice equals to
p y t t sx3
dot init
okay
then voice dot say
command
and voice
dot run
and
width
yeah
foreign
we will write like speak
now
then
so his voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytx3 engine
has started obtains a pointer to an
instance of an engine that will utilize
the specified driver
if another engine stand is already using
the given driver the other engine stance
is written if not a new engine is built
a speed now is a function in which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will run
hello how are you all
Peak now is not different okay
speak now okay and small
okay my bad ranges again
hello how are you all
hello how are you all
I hope you can hear properly so let me
run this again for another demo example
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
subscribe to simple and YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from simplerlearn yeah so I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any queries
regarding any code
or you have any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate one
here I will write speech
to web
websites
okay
speech
to web
so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition
then
import
pyts X3
then one major Library import
web browser
okay then I will run it
yeah
I hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third library
is used for
web browser is the file source code the
web browser modules offers a high level
user interface that enables users to
view web-based content
in most cases executing the open
function from the this module will
result in the desired outcome
so moving forward let me write code for
it
so I will write code first then I will
explain you line wise
so I will write
if
underscore underscore
name
then again to underscore equals to
equals to
underscore main then again underscore
then colon
yeah then you have to give a path like
for your browser you can use Edge you
can use Google Chrome anything Firefox
anything
so here I will give path path equals to
then
C drive I have my path
already
program
files
and
x 86
Microsoft
and Edge
then
okay then
application
then msh
dot e x e
you have to write at the end this
percentage s
don't forget to write this
okay so path is set so let me create Sr
equals to
speech
recognition
dot recognizer
same as previous one
and I will write with
speech underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
as source
and Sr dot adjust
or
ambient
noise
then source
now everything seems good
let me write print
but we have wrote there like speak
now please so here I will write
please
say
something
to open
okay
I will write audio
equals to
Sr Dot listen
that source
and I will print
like what you said
so it will here hearing
and I will here I try and accept
then try
so here I will write destination
equals to Sr
dot recognize
underscore Google
then audio
print
you asked
to open
right here Plus
destination
okay
so then web
browser
browser dot get
that path
then open
that destination
destination
okay
so here I will write that accept
caption
exception as
you can write e
then print
if there will be error
error
Str
okay
so I recognize the machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can use speech recognition in Python
to convert the spoken word into text you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words every time the
recognized speech from mic function is
invoked the recognizer is calibrated for
changing noise condition using the
adjust ambient noise method
a socket is all ready to receive
connection after calling the listen
function prior to performing the accept
method on the server socket the listen
method should be called the backlog
parameter of the listen function allow a
queue size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or saying
the recognize Google function on the
recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not
let me run this
okay invalid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay let me see
that print
error
Inc it should be yeah
okay let me check this
let me run this again
valid syntax perhaps you forgot a comma
okay
try to run this again
two
okay let me remove this
I guess it will work fine
still
didn't put okay okay no issues
so here I will write
again
accept
exception
e
and
errors
TR okay I forgot to write plus okay okay
e
yeah now it will work fine
www.youtube.com
so here you can see YouTube is open
yeah
so we will try this one more time
www.facebook.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
www.facebook.com
one more last time
www.simplyland.com
you can check our amazing courses on
different different Technologies here on
simply learn website simplylearn.com
data analysis is a process for acquiring
arranging and changing data so that
prediction about the future and the data
driven decision can be made
finding potential answer to business
problem is also helpful
let's move forward and see steps to
perform data analysis
so first one is Define the question what
commercial issue are you attempting to
resolve by raising it as a query you can
concentrate on coming up with a precise
response
and the second one is collecting data to
answer specified research question test
hypothesis and evaluate outcomes data
collection is the act of acquiring and
measuring information on variables of
interest in a systematic and defined
manner and the third one is cleaning
data
your data should be explored cleaned up
and deducted and organized as
unnecessary do whatever needs to be done
but wait a moment give it some time
and the fourth one is analyzing data
perform a variety of analysis to gain
insights concentrate on a descriptive
diagnostic predictive and prescriptive
types of data analysis and the fifth one
is visualization and sharing your
findings how can you most effectively
impart your knowledge and suggestions
the trick is using communication and
visualization Technologies together
after seeing the steps to perform data
analysis let's move forward and see some
importance of data analysis so python is
a high level open source interpreted
language that offers a fantastic
approach to object-oriented programming
it is the one of the greatest language
for a variety of projects and
applications according to data
scientists working with mathematical
statical and scientific function is a
base with python it provides top-notch
libraries for working with data science
application
python is the one of the most widely
used programming language in the field
of science and research due to its
Simplicity and use
this means that even those without
engineering skills might quickly learn
how to utilize it furthermore it works
better for rapid prototyping there are
some most common libraries used for data
analysis the first one is numpy
pandas
matplotlib sci-fi
C bone
and many more
so
so what do you guys think about data
analysis do share your thoughts with us
in the chat section
now let's move to our programming part
to perform data analysis using python so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
new python file
so this is how the UI looks like so at
first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in mathematical functioning so the first
one is numpy numpy is a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source projected and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so we will write
import
come by
as NB
so here NP is denoting numpy
so we will import the next libraries
pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series so we will write
import
and as
as PD
here PD is for denoting pandas so we
will
close back
so after importing the libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write data
equals to PD dot read
underscore CSV
and here we have to write our data set
name
data set
insta dot CSV
press shift plus enter yeah here PD is
for pandas Library read is used for
reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read so
then we can write data to see our data
so
see this is how our data set look like
so let's first rename this column name
followers
this one followers in Million by writing
followers only because it is so lengthy
and this followers column we are going
to use most of time so it will save our
time
so we will write here data
dot rename
column
equals to that Curly braces
here we will write the name of column
which you want to rename all words
in
sentence
colon
to followers
so here we will write in place
equals to true
okay then here we will write data
okay it's not changed yet
okay okay because it is followers
to give one space here
yeah done so rename function is a
function which is used to rename the
column name so there are many keywords
arguments like index column access copy
in place level errors which you can use
as a parameter so column name is changed
to followers let's move on so here you
can see the three dots this one
and we are unable to see our full data
like only we can see the 10 rows so like
we have thousand rows right so for that
we can write
here we can write PD dot set
underscore options
display
dot Max
underscore columns
and here we can write
none
after that this is for columns and we
can write for the same for the rows
sort underscore options
it is option not options
okay we can write here display
dot Max
underscore for rows
perfectly done okay we can write here
none
yeah so pandas features and options this
one
system that allows you to modify various
aspects of their behavior users are most
likely to change display related options
so the maximum number of rows by default
is done you can see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so the
maximum number of rows by default is 10.
all rows of data frame are considered if
the value is set to none set the display
value by setting x max rows to none and
passing it to the set option all rows
from the data frame will be shown so
let's move on
and see our full data
by writing data frame name here
so
okay let me debug the error
okay here column name
l u
MNS okay sorry
so here we can write data
so see this is how our datas look like
the Thousand rows
with full thousand rows like from 999 to
zero
yeah
so moving ahead here you can see the NN
values like this n a n and Below n a n n
so NN means not a number and it is one
of the typical methods for representing
the data set missing values it is a
unique floating point value and can only
be changed to the float type so let's
change it to 0 for the better results
and the better prediction so we will
write here data dot fill
any
zero
so by writing this we will shift plus
enter
so all n a values are now changed to
zero with the help of this fill any
function this fill in a method replaces
the null values with a specified value
so after this let's move on to the
another function which is shape
so we will write data dot shape
then shift plus enter yeah so this shape
function will return you a number of
rows and columns your data set have
so here we have thousand rows you can
see
and seven columns
yeah so let's move on to the another
amazing function which is info so here
we will write data dot info
effect so data frames information is
printed within four method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use range
index and another number of cells in
column note that the information method
does indeed print the information
so here you can see all information has
been printed like all the columns name
all the non-null values count and data
types
for the particular column so let's move
forward and see our next function which
is data dot columns so which is data dot
columns
okay again I wrote wrong
minus
okay perfect so as per the name you can
easily tell me in the chat section what
is going to print for us so
this function is going to print all the
columns name so here we have names like
name rank category followers audience
country authentic engagement engagement
average data type is object why data
type is object data type is object
because this is taking as the one
category that is why it is taking as an
object so let's move forward for the
next function which is described so data
frame comprises of numerical data and
each column's description includes it
following details like count is the
total amount of non empty values mean
the standard deviation and many others
so here we will write data Dot describe
Open brackets
so
C
so here you can see all the columns
which have numerical data is displayed
by the full description
so this is our mean
count STD minimum 25 percent of the
particular date column 50 and 70 percent
and the maximum value
present in the column so moving forward
let's solve some questions like how to
show audience country like from which
country we have the most number of
followers so let me write this question
as a comment so for comment we have to
use hashtag so here you can write how to
show
audience
from
pitch
country we have
most
number of followers
okay perfect yeah so let's solve this
with a small line of code we can write
here data
here column name as audience
entry
Dot value
underscore
counts
normalize
was to true
then we will round it it to
two
okay here we have to write the capital T
perfect
yeah
so returns an object with counts of
distinct value the resulting object will
be arranged in descending order with the
first element being the one of the that
appears most frequently by default
exclude any values index value count
normalize equals to false sort equals to
True ascending equals to false or bins
equals to none is a syntax of counting
values the normalized function in Python
processing package is used to normalize
the data it accepts an area as input and
converts its content to a range between
0 and 1. after that it will give a
backend output array with the same size
of input array if we remove round
function it will show the output like it
is still showing the values but we round
this value for how many decimal places
we have to see the value that is why I
has returned to here for two decimal
places so we will write
here
yeah the data look like good
so from this question we can say
maximum audience is from United States
with like 28 percent followed by India
like 16 percent and Brazil 15 percent
and so on
so
let's move to the other next question
which is how to show audience country
like who is having more followers from
India or a particular country
so let me write it as a comment
so
how to
audience
okay this is three hashtag
so
audience
country
like who is
having
more
followers
the question is that like who which
influencer is having more followers from
India
so
don't worry we will like do for the more
and more countries so
here I have to write data underscore
IND for India so equals to data
and again data this is our data frame
name so
audience
see
here we can write double squares to
yeah
here we can write data
so here we are giving data IND name of
you can say a variable name and data is
our data frame name and audience country
is column name and India is a country
name from which we want to collect
influencer
so let me do this
let me debug the error audience country
Okay C is capital here
yeah perfect
so
these all influencers are who has
audience from India so like Cristiano or
Virat Kohli that khabi Justin Bieber
Instagrams in the rock
and so on
so so let's take another country this
time we will take United States
so we will write here data underscore
USA
okay data
data again
and
audience
she's Capital now country
perfect
ly equals to
it is USA or United States
in the United States perfect
so United
States
so data
dot USA
this time I'm using
uh
core and Dot head
so we have to write same code like we
did for India here I have used the head
function
you can see the head function
to show only five first rows
you can also write only data USA so to
see the full data so I will write like
this I can do like this so here I can
see the full data
The influencer Who belongs to United
States that audience country belongs to
United States so
I will control that or head function
yeah
so okay let's do for One More Country
browser so let's write data
data
underscore Brazil
pursue
data
again data
accordions
is capital country equals equals to
oh Brazil how this return
[Music]
okay Brazil P capital
so here we will write Brazil
e is capital forgot
so here we will add Twitter underscore
Brazil
so we have to write same code like we
did for India and USA so here let me use
a function called tail
so
here I have used the tail function to
show only last five rows head will show
you the first five rows and the tail
will show you the last five rows so you
can also write only Brazil to see full
data so let's move forward and see our
next question which is
like how to show audience for a
particular category
so let me write this question as a
comment for your better understanding
and readability
so here we will write
how
to show
audience
for a particular
category
okay
so this time I will use fashion category
so let's write code for this one so
fashion
equals to data underscore USA
data underscore USA
right here category
okay dot Str
Dot
contains
right here fashion
comma any
equals to false
okay fashion
bats
yeah here I am using the data USA set
for retrieving the fashion category we
can do this for all the data using our
data frame name we can also write data
only here so I have given the column
names as a category and Str contains
means string which contains fashion this
is what we have to print and any should
not be false
okay so let's see
if white is showing this uh data
underscore USA
okay here f is capital
it's capital
so
yeah perfect
see these all influencers which have
audience from United States like Kendall
Jenner zandia and Beyonce
so these all influencers which I have
audience from United States and belong
to some kind of fashion industry
so moving ahead let's take one more
category this time we will take a sports
category because Sports is something
like which most of people like so we
will write here Sports
this time we will take India data set
IND I guess we have wrote the same yeah
so here we will write data
underscore
ie
and
category
same Str dot contains
okay
we will write here
we check one thing
so Sports as his capital
Sports
comma any
equals to
false
then exports again
okay this time we will use Sports dot
hat
so this time I use India data and all
the things are same just replace fashion
with the sports
so
see these are all the influencer
Cristiano Virat Kohli cabi Roy Sharma
hardik pandya which have audience from
India and belong to some kind of sports
industry so as I'm talking before like
we can use data frame name for all data
instead of using
like India data or
like this one so we can also write like
this data only
okay let me
create one more
for the
or only data so we can write like here
Sports
so
data
here we can
here we are like taking our data like
full data frame name so we can write
category
a degree name
so
dot Str dot contains
contains
ports
comma n a equals to
false
okay here we will write sport
okay
so as I'm talking before like we can use
data frame name so instead of like
writing only data and your data USA
browser so this influencers like from
Sports category belong to any one
country so this is our full
influencer category so let's move
forward and
do this again for the music category
like because music is also one of the
favorite category of you folks
so we have to write music
okay music
question
we will do is for the whole data so data
data
category
ER Dot
contains
I guess m is capital in music
yep
it's Capital so music
my n equals to
so this data will contain all the
category influencer name which belongs
to music category whether they are from
India USA Brazil or any other country
doesn't matter
see you can see Indonesia South Korean
so moving forward let's change our some
column data types to integer type
so we can write here data
equals to
data dot as type
count bracket then curly braces so here
we can write
followers
if followers followers
foreign
and take it from here authentic
engagement
overcome the spelling mistakes so I can
take from here
integer
uh
that's two four one more engagement
average
go integers
so here we can write data dot hat
yeah perfect
all the columns changed to in scissor
type now so this is how we can change
like data type in column here like data
is our data frame name
this one and the as type this one as
type
is the method like which gives a back a
new data frame with the requested data
type
for the data to select a data type for
each column you can either cast the
entire data frame so that the type or I
use Python dictionary like in the
following example like categories pearls
or whatever respectively
I repeat calories per decision are all
in like integers value respectively so
let's move to our next question which is
like top 20 character grief by follower
before making graph for this one let me
create like top variable followers
so
here I can write like 20 top
20
followers
is to
data
Dot and largest
and largest
like we need 20 so we can write here
I am writing followers spelling like
this because we have to look like this
followers f-o-l-l-wers
so
of it
yeah so top 20 followers we have taken
as a variable name to store followers
and to obtain the first and rows
arranged by The Columns in descending
order use of the enlarges function which
is this one and largest function
in specified columns are also written uh
I repeat but they are not used to
determining ranking so data frame dot
enlarges you can write the syntax like
this self comma like n comma column
names or keep you can also write keep
equals to first so top 20 followers are
generated let me create graph so
first we will import Library like one of
the main library for visualization which
is matplotlib so for importing this we
have to write import
gave so
we can also write
like
instead of writing import we can also
write from
matplotlib
both
port
Pi plot
as
LT
so for the Python programming language
and it's some bi-numerical mathematics
matplotlib is a graphing library with
the help of general purposes like GUI
toolkits like Tinker python QT and gtk
it offers an object oriented API for
embedding plots into applications
so after this let's create
the figure so we have to write PLT Dot
figure
that again figure size
equals to
we can take 12 and 8
perfect
so we will create figure 2 here
Plus 2. PLT dot bar
top 20
but we have to take followers
dot category
comma category
top
20
followers
okay followers
but
followers
comma like label should be
should be followers
it should be
like I'm taking 0.8 here
and my favorite color is maroon
so I will take
maroon color
oh
PLT
dot X sticks
font size
should be like 12 and rotation
should be 90
perfect
so let's create Y and X labels so PLT
dot y label
followers
followers
comma font size
should be let me take 16 here
and plt.x label
category
and font size should be font size
should be 16.
so let's set the title for this now for
plt.ti
title
is
up
20
categories
the words
comma
font size
should be let's
take it as 20
and PLT Dot
underscore layout
layout
listen and we can write PLT Dot
click
label
underscore format
is equals to
y
why
style should be plain
okay
so this is how the visualization look
like here I have used the bar graph for
this visualization and top 20 followers
dot category and this one top 20
followers dot followers are the X and Y
values and color is something like which
color you want to show with and you can
choose as your preference and X and Y
labels are used to print in X and Y
coordinate like this followers in
millions and category so this tight
layout this one this type layout
and
I repeat
this tight layout function this one
and this type layout function this one
this title out function in pipelot
module of matte plotly libraries used to
automatically adjust subplot parameters
to give a specified padding so plt.tick
label format is used for in which Axis
or in which style you want to print
plt.tick label is not necessary to write
or to showing paragraph So
like when we can remove this so our
visualization should look like this so
it is not necessary
okay
tools that
so let's move to our next question like
using bar graphs let's see how our
category look likes so first we will
create
I'm writing here
showing
categories
using
pie chart
okay
so using
using pie chart let's see how our
category look likes first we will create
categories so we have to write here
like types
equals to data Dot
category
Dot
value
underscore counts
and this one yeah types
okay
types
dot reset
underscore index
yeah here we have used types as a
variable and value counts uh like we
already discussed before
so these all are the categories
from our data
so let's create the pie chart now so for
plotting a pie chart we have to write
PLT dot pi
like types dot values
values comma label
should be
types dot Index this one label should be
type dot Index this music Cinema
lifestyle modeling and so on
so index
comma
label distance
equals to 1.2
and then Auto
PCD should be
like
some days 1.2
f
percentage so like
shadow
should be true
of it and let me add one more thing
start
angle
should be 60.
okay so PLT Dot
title
that is like
you can say different
categories
comma font size
should be 20
and that's PLT Dot
plot
so let me check everything is correct
values labels okay here we can write
labels
type dot values labels equals to type
dot index and label distance equals to
1.2
so here Auto PCT is equals to
like okay Shadow equals to True perfect
and starting is equals 20 60 so PLT or
title different categories okay okay
fine everything is great
so
it's not coming okay perfect so this is
how our pie chart look like this is
looking like a mess because we have more
than 100 categories that is why like 100
percent is splitting into 152 categories
like you can see here
we have 152 categories
Okay so
this is how
sorry this is how our like pie charts
look like for our different categories
let me write D capital
yeah perfect
so Microsoft developed Microsoft Excel I
spreadsheet for Windows Mac OS Android
and iOS it has calculating or Computing
capabilities graphing tools pivot table
and the Visual Basic for applications
the Microsoft Office program package
includes Excel users of Microsoft Excel
May format arrange and compute data in a
spreadsheet data analysts and other
analysts can make information easier to
examine as data is added or altered by
organizing data using tools like Excel
the boxes and excels are referred to as
cell and they are arranged in a row and
column the key features of excels are
they spreadsheet document in Ms Excel
can have headers and Footers and user
can protect their data by giving it
password protection
and the second one is filtering is
supported allowing you to locate the
necessary data in your spreadsheet and
replace it with the appropriate value
after discussing what is Excel let's go
through and see what is python so python
is the one of the most popular
programming language available today it
is widely used in various sector of
business such as programming web
development machine learning and data
science given its expected use it is not
surprising that python has surpassed
Java as a top programming language
python frequently used to create
software website and to perform data
analysis and many more because python is
a journal purple language it may use to
develop a wide range of programs and
isn't alert for any particular issues
so the key features of python are it is
open source and free
python can be downloaded from the
company official website it is simple to
download and install
pythony's open source because allowing
users with solid technical background to
modify the code to suit certain business
use case and product requirements since
python is a language for beginners most
anyone with the understanding of
programming can quick pick it up and
begin coding
so after seeing what is python let's
move forward and see what is automating
Excel with python
we all know python is dominant
everywhere and we also know that
compared to other language python is
beginner friendly and simpler to use
automation is the one of the coolest
thing you can do with python so how to
automate an Excel sheet in Python
imagine that you are asked to create
accounts for 30 000 employees on a
website what would you think you will
undoubtedly become frustrated carrying
out this talks manually and repeatedly
additionally it will take too much time
which is not the wise choice
so just try to picture that what it is
like for employers who work in data
entry
the responsibility is to extract the
data from tables like Excel or Google
sheet and insert it in the another
location they read various magazines and
website get the data there and they are
entered it into the database
additionally they must perform the
calculation for the entries in general
this job performance determines how much
money is made greater entry volume more
pay of course everyone wants a higher
salary in their job so however don't you
find doing the same things over and over
boring
the question is now
how can I accomplish it quickly
and how to automate my work spend an r
in coding and automating these kind of
course to make your life simpler rather
than performing these kinds of things by
hand by just writing fewer lines of
python code you can automate your
laborious activity in simpler
so overall python Excel automation is a
creative method that allows you to build
visual reports on python in a smoother
manner similar to how you would on Excel
businesses can use Python Excel
automation to streamline their operation
in accordance with their requirements
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see the answers
are given by you are correct or not I'm
repeating again here is one question for
you guys I will give you one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so
the question is which type of
programming does python support
object oriented programming structured
programming functional programming and
all of the mentioned
so I'm repeating again which type of
programming does python support
option a object oriented programming
option b structured programming
functional programming and all of the
mention
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answers in comment
section or in chat section do let me
know your answers guys so like please I
want that everyone should participate in
this so I am starting the timer
so
so your time starts now
so I want that everyone should
participate in this guys please do let
me know your answer in chat section or
in comment section
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong so
like 36 seconds or more
is guys I want that everyone should
participate in this so
let me know your answers in chat section
or comment section
so you can just type the answers or a b
c d
your wish totally your wish so
10 seconds are left guys hurry up please
I want that everyone should participate
in this five second more
okay so time is over we will give reply
those who gave correct answers and those
who didn't give correct answer we will
give you a reply with the correct answer
okay so no worries
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform Excel automation using
python so first we will open command
prompt to write command to open Jupiter
notebook computer
notebook
yeah
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
select here new open new file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in importing our workbook
or worksheet so the first one is let me
first rename this
we will write Auto meeting
cell
using python
yeah sounds good
okay
so the first one is Open PI Excel open
py
Excel okay I have to write import yeah
perfect
so a python package called open pyxl can
read and write Excel 2010 xlx format
Excel SM format xltx and xltm files
it was created since there was no
library that could read and write office
open XML files natively from python
since open py Excel was initially based
on PHP Excel all praised to the PHP
Excel team so open py Excel does not by
default provide protection from your
quadratic blow up or billion laughter
XML as sold installed diffused XML to
protect yourself from these assault so
we will write open py Excel and then
like
yeah
so
then we will write for important our
workbook so we can write here from open
p y Excel
report
workbook
code
underscore workbook
is capital here
so and this is for code for the
importing our workbook so let me write
in command like you can import workbook
like this so I can write you can import
workbook
this
okay perfect
yeah
so
here
let me import workbook then
so I have to write WB for Workbook
question
load
underscore workbook
the destination of the workbook so uh
the destination is in like desktop so I
have to write C
users
lp09
375
stop
Dash automation
that
we learn
Dot
cell SX format
okay cool
users SLP this one desktop automation
simply learn DOT xlx fine
so our workbook is loaded to Jupiter
notebook
we can see yeah perfect no error so
let's activate this workbook for the use
so we have to write WS for worksheet so
worksheet equals to WB DOT active
active
like import from openmpi Excel our book
there must be always been one worksheet
in a workbook it is accessible through
the workbook dot property active so
that's why we have write WB DOT active
so after making workbook active so we
will print our workbook like
we can print
so print
WS
so here
so here you can see the sheet one so it
is showing worksheet sheet1 why sheet1
because if you open your workbook and
see here is your worksheet name like
like so this is my automation
file
this is simply learn
so here you can see
the shade one
that is why it is showing sheet1 there
so uh okay so let me just
finish it
so moving forward
let's change the worksheet name so
I will write here import
open
pyxl
so like it's your wish that you want to
write this import file or like this
thing this is not necessary at all so
now I will import the workbook so I will
write here
WB equals to open py Excel
dot load underscore
workbook
when pyx L it is
my bad sorry guys
so
you have to give the path so I can copy
path from here
yeah perfect
okay sounds good
yeah yeah WB underscore sheet
equals to
WB and square brackets then you have to
write the sheet name so there we have
sheet 1.
sheet 1.
so sheet1 okay correct
so I can change with WB underscore sheet
dot title
sheet
dot title
equals to
code with
simply learn
perfect
yeah seems good let me save this
WD dot save
and the same
copy
here paste
yeah
so when a sheet is generated it
immediately receives a name like they
have sequential numbers of names like
sheet sheet1 sheet 2 and so on with the
worksheet you can modify this name
whenever you want to like using the
title property so
here let me save this
and yeah where are
so again go to Simply learn
yeah you can see code base simply learn
first it was sheet1 and now it is
changed to codebase Simply learn
so let me cut this again
okay
so if you want to change the color of
your sheet name tab whereas written code
will simply learn so you can write like
here
you can write
WD
or okay let me make this new one
okay right I will write here so
underscore sheet
dot sheet
underscore properties
app
color
was to
here you have to give hex
values so four zeros okay
so let me save this okay it is saying
sheet1 why sheet1 because we already
changed sheet1 to code which simply
learn so what we have to do is
here we have to write code with
simply learn
relearn
okay same same simply learn simply learn
same code code yeah so what I will do
here I will just
make W Capital so yeah
now it will work fine yeah
so
if you save or run your code like like
this let me
let me show you one thing uh like
color is already changed wait for one
minute guys I will show you something
crazy so it will see like this w
ok
so here I will small
so
if you save or run your code not
actually save but run your code while
your Excel sheet is open so my Excel
sheet is open code will simply learn
yeah
so my Excel sheet is open so it will
give you error like where
repeat like whatever
this okay let me do one thing this is
one okay
it will give you
the brilliant one does not exist let me
check this is simply learn code will
simply learn
one
code with okw's capital there
okay see this is a
permission denied
then the location it is showing
permission denied
so this is something important to
remember that Excel file should be
closed while running the code and
repeating again so like this is
something important to remember that
Excel file should be closed while
running the code
so first what I have to do is close the
Excel file
then I have to run it again so no error
now
so here you can see
what we simply learn that red color came
yeah perfect
so moving forward let's create new
workbook till we were working on the
same worksheet which was present me in
my like desktop so let's create new vagu
so for that I have to write
import
cell as X writer
so I will write here in command to
create
new notebook
WB equals to excel SX
writer
Dot
workbook
and where you want to
save the workbook so I will give
the same
path
but with different name
so this time I will give only like
coders simply
okay simply coders
then I will write WD class close
okay I will run it yeah
so the primary class export by the XLS
writer module in the workbook class and
that is only class you will need to
instantiate directly so the workbook
class represents both the whole
spreadsheet as it appears in the Excel
and the Excel file as it is stored on
the disk internally
so you can see now
yeah you can see now
the workbook which is created in the
desktop with the same name is like
simply coders
so this is done
let's move forward and let's retrieve
cell values so right now we are not
having any data inside the workbook so
let's put some random values like names
and all so uh
I will put some random values
we'll put here
names
okay
mayank
kaushal
okay
well
like jelly
Chloe
so let's save it
let's save it
and let's move to our coding part so
here what I have to write to retrieve
cells here I just write a equals to A is
variable here
so I am assigning is WS
that
A1 value
the value which is presented at A1
so here I will write in comments
like
to
retrieve cells
okay
so here I will print
print
a
okay okay
what I have to do is like we have
created this one file so it's it is not
giving
the uh this is giving sheet1 dot A1 why
because it is taking from the simply
coders one so what I can do is I can
import this file because we have saved
data in this file
so it bases here and make it active
get active yeah
so yeah you know I haven't write here
value
so that is why it is giving the cell
name and that A1 name cell name A1 only
so now it will print
aims why why names
because at the A1
at the A1 position we have names so if
you want to like print Anjali so what
you have to do is okay let me check this
B3 okay
if you want to print Anjali you have to
just write here just copy paste this
code
okay just right here the location
B3
you can see Angel is printed
so this is how you can retrieve cells
and we can do the same for the others as
to
so there is one thing like retrieving
we can change the sales values too
so just we have to write here so let me
give first enter enter for the better
visual
yeah
so here what we can write is WS
like I want to change the name of a name
of name of
uh
I will take this A4 Smith
let me close this
okay
I will give here A4
dot value
equals to here you can give the value so
here you can write Smith you can write
John
here as a replaced value
so I will write here in as a command
change
cell
value
okay
so what you have to do is just save it
WB dot save
you have to give the path for the same
yeah
fine
so let me save this and
let me save this first and run this
first okay no error and let's open our
workbooks to see the changes
so here you can see
the changes has been implemented in our
workout
first there it was like Smith and now
John so like this you can change the
cell values and let's move forward and
see how we can merge the cells in a
worksheet
so like just close this and yeah
so we are doing for the merging cells so
here I will write from
open py Excel
dot styles
import
alignment
so here I will write
much cells
for your better understanding
okay
so here I have to write WB equals to
workbook
okay let me active this workbook
WB DOT active
merge
the cell
set which one uh let's take for a while
A1
and B2
okay A and B should be in capital
letters
so after that we have to save this
we will save in this only
so I can copy I can paste it here
okay
fine
like using merge underscore cells and
after giving cell position you can
easily merge the cell so let's see the
output so let me open this simply learn
file
you can see
Nima they are merged together and like
but what if you want the values at the
same times
so you can write here I have to cut this
so you can write here like
from open py Excel
dot styles
what
alignments
alignment a should be capital
alignment
okay
so the same thing you have to write wdb
equals to
workbook
WS equals to
WB DOT active
don't have to give parenthesis
WS dot merge
underscore cells
cells
A1
B2
so here I have to give the cell value
equals to WS dot cell
which row which column so I can write
row equals to 1
column
equals to 1.
so cell
dot value
equals to
here you can give the value which you
want to print at the cell so here I will
write code with simply learn
okay fine
so what we can do this we can give the
alignment
alignment equals to
alignment
horizontal horizontal
equals to Center
and from vertical
and from vertical the same
Center
okay let me save this file WB dot save
at the same location so I can copy the
path from here
copy here and paste here so I will
yeah seems good let me save this
white is giving error uh cell object has
no attribute alignment okay alignment
spelling is wrong
sorry my bad
g and m e and t
eight seems good now
oh good to go
so
so here you can see
like by giving rho equals to one column
equals to one basically position and
after giving the value to what to print
on that cell and one more thing is
alignment like it is not necessary to
give alignments like I just wrote it to
cover it uh like in video so you can
give alignments like uh right left this
time I gave the center to print in the
center
so let's
move and see the results
so you can see the value has been
printed exactly at the center of the
cell
I will make it like this you can see
the value is printed exactly at the
center of the cell because I gave the
alignment center so let's do one more
for like
to see what is the default place if you
don't give the alignments okay if you
don't give the center alignments what is
the default value so let me first remove
this okay save no issues
okay yeah
so
we have a line
alignments
or here what we can do is like
from
UI Excel dot styles
import
alignment
is not necessary to light import
alignments
okay this is without
okay I can write this default
live
seems good
okay everything we have to cover from
here so I can just copy from here and
paste it here
so what we will do here we will change
the cell value we will use like C
six and B
it
sorry guys so
uh here I have to give row
equals to 6
and column must be
eight so let's make it be cs6b6
okay let's column should be six
so code will simply learn coders of
Simply learn
orders of Simply learn like we are
giving the value
so at the same time we have to just save
it WB dot save
copy
paste here
okay
so this time we are not giving the
alignments you can see here we have gave
alignments not now
so let's run this and after that we will
open our workbook
so this is saying merge cells
okay 2 must be greater than 3. okay so
here what is happening
okay I can write here D6
right
so now it will run properly I guess yeah
it's working
so
let me open this
so you can see
this is the default value of like
it so here you can see the value is
printed at its default location
not in centered or not in right not in
left it is default location
so till now we know how to merge cell so
I repeat I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so
moving forward
until now we know how to merge cells so
let's learn how to earn muscle okay so
let me open the code
yeah
let me open the code and write for you
so let me quickly write the code how we
can merge cell so we can write open
from
open
y
Excel
dot styles
you just I can copy this from here
I have to write here import alignments
alignment only
so what we are doing here we will not
give any value or any this
so here I will remove like B6
actually we can give
like a
six
P6 as a value
so let's see the cells are merged or Not
by running it
okay see permission denied because our
Excel was opened so let me save this and
close it
and turn it again no error
so
here you can see
let me Zoom if I can yeah so as you can
see A6 and B6 are merged so what should
I do to unmerge I have to write
yes you can write here like
where you can write WS Dot unmerge
underscore cells
okay cells
got it
and just give this same value
A6 underscore B6
okay colon B6
let me save this again no error let me
open the file
so you can see here
A6 and B6 now unmerged
so by just using unmerged cells you can
easily unmerge the cells in your
workbook
so let's move forward and see how can
you set dimensions for a particular cell
or column
so
let me close this and go to the workbook
again
this is something frustrating by like by
regularly doing the same thing going
next next next
so like you need a particular column
height should be something and which
should be something so that is what I'm
like meant to be Dimensions so let's
write code for it you will see and
understand by seeing so
import
open p y Excel
#to set
dimensions
of a particular
cell
okay
WB equals to
open p y Excel
dot workbook
worksheet equals to
workbook DOT active
ws.row underscore dimensions
yeah
one I will explain you don't worry
height
equals to
let me give 70 for a while
okay w s dot column
underscore
dimension
wait I will explain you don't worry
don't worry it
so let me save the file WB dot save
and let me copy the path from here
okay
everything seems good
okay
y column okay column name is like
functional column Dimension okay
dimensions
all right so like one height 70 and B
width is eight
color one let me open the workbook
so here you can see
by giving row Dimension and column
Dimension and by adding height and width
then we can set the dimension for a
particular cell y1 and B for this
you can see here 1 for the column like 2
for the column 3 for the column let me
Zoom it
you can see now one for the all the one
column Row 2 for the two Row 3 for the
three row like this
for you can say I use one for the
particular row or you can say one for
denoting row particular Row one two
three four five six like this
chicken I repeat
and particular alphabet to denote the
column see a for this column B for this
column C for this column D for this
column like this okay
so here you can see every cell of Row
one has the same height this this this
this this this this this this and every
cell of
bit and every cell of column B has same
width
BS same width
so
like we can do one more thing we can
print
value though in a particular cells like
okay let me
just close this
and open do this one
so what can I do is I can write
here
like we can write at wd's cell
rho equals to 1
comma column
equals to 1.
okay
dot value
equals to
hello
okay and WS dot cell
here I will write rho equals to 2
comma column
equals to 2
dot value
dot value
equals to
coders
so I have to write it here not below
this yeah
okay cool let me give this space line
okay so let me save this
and
let me check
so here you can see
hello is for the row one and coder at
the column B
okay fine
so let me close this and
okay next I repeat next let's see how we
can move data to a particular row or
column or you can say a particular cell
here we need data to make it move so
let's fill some random data
on it so what I can do is
I can put some random data
of like
fruit
vegetables
and some names like Maya
Angeli
above
social
oh no
and we can give like
anything is Smith
John
and Chloe
Sarah
and
all right Sachin
okay
I think this much is enough so let me
save this
and yeah
so data part is done and let's move to
the this one and write import
open pyxl
so let me write here move
so
you can say move or jump whatever you
want to say so from open p y Excel
import
workbook
command load
underscore workbook
will be equals to
load
can give the path like this yeah
C and we
okay let's make it active WS equals to
WB DOT active
of X seems good okay
so I have to move WS
dot move
score range
this is I can give okay let me see
the data first
okay I will make
an above here
and
blank here
or here
okay
so let's see again I forgot it is B
5 and A4
B5 A4
okay
so what we can do it uh like
oh
e
five
comma like row
plus two two
and call
it V rows equals to and calls equals to
so let me save this w dot save
and let me
so here what I'm doing is changing the
position of the value which is present
in the location
A4 and B5 so and moving them by you can
say the value will jump by two rows and
two columns because I gave here two rows
rows equals to 12 columns equals to 2.
so let me save this run this okay
and
so here you can see
so let me run this
and what you have to do is open this
file
yeah
so you can see A2 means one two
it comes fruit comes here and coders
come here so this is how you can move
your
coding part
I repeat so this is how you can move
these cell values so let's move forward
and
see so moving forward let's see how we
can insert a row in our workbook okay so
first what I will do is
I will add some data like
name here like fruits
and something like car
and here I can like bike
okay
something here coding
okay all the data is filled and all rows
are filled by some values so here we
have no like no empty row present here
till now so what we will do is
we will insert a row
okay so what we have to write is import
open p y Excel
hashtag
insert
goes
okay
from open p
ixel
port
book
comma load
let's go
load
all right
let me copy the path
see
so let me make it active
so I want to insert row
deposition to
and one more row
at the position 5.
so let me save this I will copy from
here
okay
I will make like this so let me save
this no error
let's move to the workbook
you can see here Row 2 is created and
Row 5 is created with no values
so
as you can see rows are added to the
particular position or you can say the
indexes
so we have seen how we can insert the
rows let's see the deletion of the rows
so what we can write is let me open the
code
so what we can write is let me copy to
save our time
okay just delete this
so we can write
WS
dot delete
the score
and which row
2 5 uh I will delete row number two
for a while
so let me save this
and run this
so you now you can see empty Row 2 is
deleted
so by using insert rows and giving them
index you can insert the row at the
index position you give and meanwhile
you can use delete underscore rows
function to delete the particular row so
moving forward let's quickly write code
for the insert column
so for inserting column
I will copy from here
yeah insert row
column
and this one is for
relating
row
okay
so I have to write here WS
Dot
active not active sorry insert
calls add the position
second
okay at the position one and
okay I will make it
insert
calls at the position three
okay
let me save this file by copying this
path
okay saving let me do one thing
perfect
so let me open the workbook
so here what I've done is insert call at
second position here we can't give
alphabet we have to give a number for
denoting a position so
as you can see the column is added at
the position one
and three
so by using insert underscore calls and
by giving index you can insert column in
your workbook
so let's do one thing guys
okay first let me close this and yeah
so what I was saying that let's do one
thing guys
you will tell me how can I delete a
particular column
okay let me write here
the question
comments like
how
can
you
delete a
particular
particular
column
okay
I'm giving you one minute for this just
comment the code for this column
deletion or else you can reply on chat
it will suggest you to write a comment
because after this session our team can
easily check who gave the correct answer
and who didn't give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide you the
answers at the end of the session or our
team will reply at your comment at the
same time
so uh like for those who are watching
this video like we watch normal video
means you are not watching the live
session so what you can do is just pause
the video right now and put the comment
how you can delete the column
I am repeating again I will suggest you
to write a comment because after this
session our team can easily check who
gave the correct answer and who didn't
give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide you the
answer at the same time
or our team will reply at your comment
at the same time
and those who are watching the video
like we watch normal video
so that you can do is just you can pause
this video and put the comment how you
can delete the column
so I guess time is up guys I hope most
of you gave the correct answers by
putting comments we will verify your
comments and we will back to you soon so
okay moving forward let's see how we can
style the font in Excel
okay this is something crazy and
interesting
so you will not get bored and writing
from open py Excel
dot styles
import
font
so here I will write for your styling
okay
so what I can do is like WB is equals to
open
p y Excel dot workbook
blue s dot
equals to WB DOT active
I will don't worry I will explain you
rho equals to 1
comma column
equals to 1 equals to
um
relearn
okay
and I will set the size of the cell
so WS equals to
sell
row equals to
1
comma
column
equals to 1
Dot
value
here I have to write font
equals to
font
equals to
font and you have to write size
equals to 24.
okay here I have to give
dot value
we can do it for the many others
but we will do it
we will
change
hello
not world again we will write coder
hello coders and
here we will add code with
simply learn
and here we will write
hello YouTube
yeah
so
what I will do is like it will
2 column two row two
two here
what I will do is font size equals to
24 and and I will make it italic
question
true
okay fine and I will make it
old
because true
and here I will give
three
three
okay and at the end what I can do is
okay bye
Thanks new
one
so let me save it quickly
WB dot save
with a fart
so let's run this and see the results
so let's run this again one more time
so here what I did is just gave the
particular row and column value where we
want to print the value like simply
learn hello coders hello YouTube code
which simply learn
okay and by using font I am giving the
font size and font like italic bold and
so on like this is italic this is bold
okay and here you can see at the End by
using name here you can see
at the End by using name
we are assigning the styles of the
particular text like Times New Roman and
you can give the name of your choice
so why it is not because
I have gave the it is collapsing
so here I have write 444 okay now it
will it is collapsing now hello YouTubes
and simply learn
so what I will do is now I will run
now you can see
yeah perfect
so this is simple one this is it in
italic this is in bold and this hello
YouTube is in Times New Roman Style
okay
so okay let's move forward and do
something with cells
um like what we can do it let's do color
them okay
let's add code for this
how we can like color a particular cell
we know how to color the particular tab
of sheet
and now
let's color it so we can write as import
open py Excel
here I will write coloring
particular
cell
okay
so I will first copy this thing here
from here
okay I don't think I want this I have to
write from open
UI Excel
port
and fill
I want something like this
okay so WD dot open py Excel workbook
here I can write open pyxl
dot load workbook
okay
book
and here I will give the path
yeah it seems good
so what I will do is
make it active and I can write here WS
equals to
WB
square brackets then I can write a name
of working sheet
I don't remember
only sheet
sheet
so we can write a fill underscore cell
equals to pattern
will
ATT pattern
type should be I will prefer solid
okay
and
comma
FG color
foreground color equals to
I will write here f
c 2 C
0 3 okay
fine we can make four cells
four cells
four cells are enough I guess so we can
write here cell one
paste copy paste copy paste so we'll
look for
three
two
solid solid solid yeah
so let's change color we can give 0 3
FC
F4
here I will give
3 5 F C 0 3.
perfect
here I can give
o f c
a 0 3.
so now let me assign
let me assign the cells to them WS
like
you can assign a
a 1.
sine A2
dot fill
equals to
fill
underscore cell
KR
ill
underscore cell one
that seems good
this I can make it for four we we
mra2
84 A5
A3
everything seems good
let me save this so I will copy from
here
why error permission denied because it
was open so let me cut this
so let me see
so here I'm using the pattern field to
fill the color and solid style and
giving the FG color like foreground
color
and at the below you can see I'm like
assigning the cells to a particular
pattern field cells so
let's see the output yeah it's working
here you can see the results we colored
these for the particular cell like A2 A3
A4 A5
so this is something you can style the
color so let's move forward and see how
we can import the image in our workbook
like something here something here
something here let's see
so let me first cut this okay
let me do one more thing yeah perfect
coloring particular cell
so how we can import
our file or image you can say
so I will write
from
open p y Excel
both
load underscore workbook
okay load underscore workbook load
underscore workbook
and
I have to write F from
open p by Excel
dot drawing
dot image
import image
okay fine
workbook
write w d equals to
load underscore
workbook
okay
let me copy this and this hole
so logo is for
variable used for the image image
okay so I don't have an image for right
now
let me do one thing
uh let me import one image
any kind of image for a while so I can
do like
so this is my image
what can I do is
what can I do is I can give the path
like
uh
path would be same
path would be same
we will change here something don't
worry don't worry
X stop
don't remember name of the file this is
picture two
yeah
piece is smaller capital
p is capital so I have to write
picture
2 dot PNG
so
I will give logo
dot height equals to 150
logo
dot width
equals to
150 a bit of resizing to not fill the
whole spreadsheet with the logo
so that's why just for that so WS dot at
image
to logo
comma
cell in which cell you want to print I
will M two
fine
so here we will
save it
by using this one
okay perfect
cannot image import name image from
mobile file drawing during this one
so might be there is problem
open p y Excel Dot
drawing
dot image
okay
import image
I think I is capital s
James
logo image okay ice Capital here
yeah it seems good
yeah here is the picture so what I do is
what can I do is
so here we need one more Library drawing
image a variable logo this one
is for the location of the image and
giving and height and weight because a
bit of resizing to not fill the whole
spreadsheet with a logo like with the
whole spreadsheet with the logo so just
a bit of resizing
and add image function is used to append
image on it and M2 is for like this M2
M2 is for position m
2 like that it's for in which cell you
want to append it so
image is is coming to the particular
index M2
okay
so this is how you can import image and
Excel using python okay let's move
forward and see how we can import date
and time so let's write code for that
quickly
okay
so what I will do is I will write here
import
date time
I will write
date
time
from
open py Excel
import
workbook
time
so what can I do is
make it WP equals to
workbook
low should be Capital here
and WS equals to WB DOT active
what can I write is Ws dot cell
row 1
comma column
goes to 1
dot value
equals to
date
and time
something
so I can copy it
paste it
what I can do is
let me first change the
three
oh
equals to 3.
okay
value
so here I can assign date and time
date
time dot date time dot now
Dot string
format strf
time
what you have to write it percent y
percent M for month
percent D for days
percent h
then percent
I am for minutes and percent
against
so this should be
in between this
okay
yeah but
so let me save this
close it
import date start time not date time
it's date time
okay row equals to 1.
data time not date time
again
date time dot now
a Time Dot date time
so daytime objects has no attribute strf
time okay time it is yeah
okay yeah
Finance working no errors
so air like okay
so here I have imported some libraries
like date time and so on strf time used
for string formatter and date time now
used for the current date time this date
time now is used for the current date
time
and so let's run this and see
so here you can see the correct time and
date is coming it can be different from
your from which country you are watching
this live session
so
what if you want to print the time after
like two seconds late
so for that we can write here
quickly
so I will copy this whole
we
so like
we have to copy this and just what you
have to do is
let me make for to see the difference
v v okay three are enough
so what I will do is
go four
five
okay fine what I will add here is time
dot sleep
how much second you want like two
for this one and
something for this one like
five seconds for this one
okay
so what we can do is let's save it
and let's see the results
so here I've used the time dot slim
function given parameter as two or four
I guess five operating the seconds
difference
so here you can see the difference in
seconds okay the time is not coming wait
wait let me check
sorry guys
now I have to turn it
open it
and it is not coming why so
shouldn't denied
okay
let me run it again
okay okay because I am giving seconds
difference not that way that is why is
giving permission denied so let us wait
for two five five seconds
okay I think five seconds are over
now we can open it
yeah you can see 47 seconds and 49s two
second difference and 49.54 five second
different
so here I've used the time slip function
given parameter as 25 for printing the
second different
so let's move to the workbook
here you can see the difference in
seconds so I hope you understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
I'm repeating again I hope you
understand till here if you have any
questions or any doubt
or any query regarding any code or
whatever it is so just put as in
comments or our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
so moving forward
moving forward let's see how we can add
values as an array
okay
so what I will write import
xlsx
writer
WB
equals to xlsx
writer Dot
workbook
okay I will give the path
from here
okay WS equals to
WB dot at
worksheet
W should not be Capital here
okay so what I will do is rho equals to
0
and column equals to 0.
okay so I will write here uh
data
equals to
and take us the names just names
we
just random names they are
above let's take
one more
so
for
atom
and data
and WS
dot right
I will explain you line by line don't
worry
rho comma
column
comma item
perfect so here what I will do is rho
plus equals to 1 or you can write rho
equals to rho plus 1
w b Dot
close
okay
let's save this
let's see our data is appended or not
okay first I will explain this code to
you
so here I have created one new workbook
like name
no I haven't created so let me create
two
okay
example
okay
so I will run this yeah perfect so yeah
I repeat so here I have created one new
workbook name example
so at row 0 column 0 I am printing my
content values
like for data values using for loop I am
moving to the next iteration of the
values like from undue to core shoe and
then mayank then so on
so let's see the results
okay
yeah
so here you can see all the values are
printed so using these chords of line
you can do things like this easily
so as we know how to write multiple
values at the same time what if if you
want to retrieve values of a particular
row or column so for that we need
so we need data for that so let me add
the full data
of let let me
copy some data from somewhere
so just give me a minute
okay
it's the blank worksheet
let me give me one minute guys
okay what I will take is
this one
I can take this
some values we can copy like 50 values
okay
50 is high enough
see
yeah
yeah
we have data now
yeah
we have data in the simply learn okay
now we can write code for that like how
to retrieve multiple column
so the same
font
see
let's do WB
DOT active
okay
WS
a question
WB
red sheet
column
in worksheet
a
okay
so what I have to do is just print
column values
column dot value
I hope it will work uh
WB DOT active
workbook object has no attribute active
okay let me see
um okay sorry
import open p y Excel
XLS writer is used for
to create new workbook okay open p y
Excel
dot load
underscore workbook
now it will work I guess
still it is not working
note
it should work I guess
open pyxl
open by Excel dot load okay okay sorry
my bad here Dot
now it will work okay sheet
too much this is [ __ ] one
you never know
when the sheet will create
one
yeah
you can see all the list of column A is
printed here
all the 50 values and you can match from
here to
all the 50s values okay Trail Travis
Scott
so let me match this
okay
so
I hope you understand till here if you
have any questions or any query
regarding any code so just put as in
comment or our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution after doing
importing exporting the values and all
let's perform some basic operation like
addition average and all okay
so first we will start with the addition
so I will write here so we need data in
workbook for the addition
so let's take some data from
from which set
the same install data set
so I will take this
this
values are enough
okay
copy it
and let me paste here
so our data we have let's code for it
we have to write here import
open p y Excel
we are doing sum of columns
not column column values values
yeah
like from open
p y Excel import
book
comma load underscore workbook
so WB equals to load
underscore
a note workbook
copy the path
a
so I will make it active
so here what I'm doing is
I will tell you shortly
so it is in C I guess C or p
which column
of
P
oh B 50
one I guess yeah
P51
B should be capital
equals to
see carefully what I'm doing like sum
from B one
one
till
B I guess 50 values we have 50.
okay B should be Capital my bad sorry
okay this is what I'm doing and WDS dot
save
where is the same one
so here I have added all the values
which are between in the range of B1 to
B 50.
and what I'm doing is the result will be
displayed on the b51 cell
okay so let's run this code
okay
let's go to the b51
yeah result is coming for verifying the
result is correct or not I won't use
calculator
for this so we can use
this code for the same for average
product and count so let's
do it quickly
okay
so let me just copy paste this stuff
c v this is will be for
average
a spelling mistake average
okay what I will do is just write
Capital heavy
Bridge here
okay and I will print it to 50
2.
okay code is almost same just one chain
like you have to write instead of sum
you have to write average
there
and just okay
let's see then
so now you can see this is the 137 point
something something is the average of
these all values
everything look good
let's see the count
weekly let's
be
Port is almost same just we have to
okay capital
fifty three
visible okay
this count will give you how many values
are there between the range till 1 to
50. so let's check let's run it again
and check
if it's working or not yeah 49 values
okay
so
what I'm planning is let's do one thing
now guys uh you will tell me how I can
find the product of a particular range
I'm writing question as a command as I
did before
so
how to
okay
okay
how to find
product
of numbers
like where
yeah
at the range is between
a A2 to a 98
okay
so I'm
giving you one minute for this just
comment the code for this like
multiplication uh or else you can reply
on chat you can write just syntax only
for the product
I will suggest you to write a comment
because after this session our team can
easily check who gave the correct answer
and who didn't give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide the answers
at the end of this session or our team
will reply at your comment at the same
time
and those who are watching the video
like we watch normal video or you are
not attending the live session so you
can just pause this video and comment on
how we can find the product in Excel
using python
I am repeating again I will suggest you
to write a comment because after this
session our team can easily check who
gave the correct answer and who didn't
give the correct answer don't worry I
will provide you the answers at the end
of this session or our team will reply
at your comment at the same time
those who are watching this video like
we used to watch normal videos uh so
what you can do is just pause this video
and comment on how we can find the
product in Excel using python
so I guess time is up guys I hope most
of you gave the correct answer by
putting comments we will verify your
comments and we will back to you soon
so moving at the last
of this session let's do something with
charts so what I will do is first I will
move it bit up
yeah
so let me write code for that for the
chart
so I will write from open
p y Excel
import
workbook
um
open p y Excel
dot chart
import
reference
comma
line chart
okay we will create line chart WB equals
to workbook
WS it equals to
workbook DOT active
so after this I will set the chart title
title equals chart
okay
okay let me create these rows so rows
equals to
uh I will do is
I will create something like
um
X
okay comma
uh
sale
comma
veggiesel
yes
Oma
not here
comma
and I have to give the values weeks are
Monday
okay let me keep this same
Hotel should be like 100
comma 200
Tuesday
from a 200
comma 300
Wednesday
300
comma 400
but
the Thursday
400
or 20 30.
hey
20
comma
at the day
60 comma 30.
okay it seems good
let me do
like four
rows
okay Row in rows
blue s dot append
oh
values
equals to
reference
WS comma min
call
s to 2 comma Main
rho equals to 1
comma Max
column equals to 3
comma Max
underscore row equals to 7.
okay it seems good okay x dot values
equals to
reference
the score string
equals to
chart
A2
A7
so chart equals to line chart we are
making
so let's add the data to line chart
object
chart
dot add underscore data
values
comma titles
t i t
t i t l e s titles
let's go from underscore data
construct row
okay
it should be capital
so let's set x axis
chart dot set
categories
X underscore values
okay let's set chart
Dot
let's go
tails
chart Dot
access
l equals to
weeks
and chart
dot y
axis
dot title
equals to
root
and
veggies
sales
chart dot Legend
dot position
equals to B
okay
so WS dot add
underscore chart
comma
H1 cell
so WB okay let me copy this code from
here
so here I am importing reference and
charts Library like this reference and
charts Library
and just giving title as charts you can
see here chart
so rows are the data from which we will
make chart
and for Loop is to append the data on
the workbook
chart add data chart add data
values titles from data equals to true
this is for adding data to the line
chart object just giving the title X
action and y axis
and all so let's save this and see
whether chart is visible or not
let's save this
okay what is going cannot import name
reference from open file
reference okay let me see
error in line two
error in line two
okay sorry my bad okay
now it will workbook
forward number okay W should be capital
should be Capital now it will work I
guess
again that's reference
okay
extort values
dot my bad
h a r t
c h a r t
dot save okay WB Dot
okay finally no error
so let's save this and see whether chart
is visible or not
let me go to this simply learn
yeah you can see chart is coming and it
is it's looks so good
so renting CDs and DVDs reading local TV
listenings watching film strip
projectors or recordings all of this is
a thing of the past today
all of the world's biggest film
collection have been digitized and moved
to the online streaming services like
Netflix HBO or YouTube
these platform can now help us with what
is possibly the most difficult task of
all choosing a movie they have been
enhanced with AI powered capabilities
well that is no longer a concern for you
it is final time for machine learning to
put its skills on display in the modern
cinematic landscape
to create Advanced predictive system for
True movie expert data scientists are
prepared to investigate our behavioral
patterns and those of movies
a movie recommendation system also known
as a movie recommender system uses
machine learning to predict or filter
user fill preferences based on their
prior decision and actions it is an
advanced filtration system that
anticipate the consumer in question
potential like selection for a domain
specific item a movie
so after seeing what is movie
recommendation system let's move forward
and see how movie recommendation system
actually works a movie recommendation
system fundamental idea is a pretty
straightforward every recommender system
primarily consists of two components
users and items user receive more
prediction from the system and the
actual movies are the products filtering
and predicting only the movies that a
matching user is most likely to wish to
see in the main objective or movie
recommendation system the user
information from the system database is
used by the ml algorithm for these
recommendation system
based on information from the past this
data is used to forecast the user in
question's behavior in the future
data should be handled by expert because
it is so crucial to ml projects
including the movie recommendation
system
after seeing how movie recommendation
system works let's see some filtration
strategies for movie recommendation
system
to assist user in finding the most
relevant films movie recommendation
system employ a variety of filtration
techniques and algorithm
the content-based filtering and the
collaborative filtering system
subcategories of the ml algorithm used
for the movie recommendations are the
most well liked ones
filtering based on content or content
based filtering a method of filtering
movies in a movie recommendation system
that makes advantage of the item's data
this information which is taken from the
just one user is quite important in this
case
this technique uses an ml algorithm to
suggest movies that are comparable to
the user's past choices therefore the
information about the prior movie
choices and likes just one person is
used to generate similarity in
content-based filtering
and the second one is collaborative
filtering as the name implies this
filtering technique is based on the
interaction between the relevant person
and the other user for the best outcomes
the system contrast and compare these
behaviors it combines the film choices
and users patterns of several people
like there are two types of
collaborative filtering algorithm the
first one is collaborative filtering
based on users the goal is to find
patterns in Target users and other
database users like movie preferences
and the second one is collaborative item
based filtering the fundamental idea
behind this is to find comparable
products products like movies that
Target users rate or interact with so
after seeing the filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system so here
is one question for you guys
I will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
one minute exactly one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which is the best
language for machine learning
programming
which is the best language for machine
learning the first one is Java the
second one is python the third one is R
language and the fourth one is C plus
plus
so this is the question I am repeating
again which is the best language for
machine learning
so option one is Java second python R
language and C plus plus
so I am starting timer of one minute
just type your answers in comment
section or in a chat section do let me
know your answers
please I want that everyone should
participate in this and make this live
session interesting
so I am starting timer
oh your time starts now
please guys do let me know your answers
in chat section or in you can comment
down
42 seconds to go
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong
30 seconds more
which is the best language for machine
learning
you can give your answer to chat section
or you can comment
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong guys come on please I
want that everyone should participate in
this and make this live section
interesting
come on guys five second more
one
yup time up
so time is over we will give reply those
who gave correct answer and those who
didn't give correct answer we will give
you a reply with the correct answer
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform movie recommendation
system using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select here new
new python file
so this is how jupyter notebook UI look
likes so at first we will import some
major libraries of python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP
so number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so here NPD in NPS denoting numpy so we
will import the next Library
port
pandas as
PD
this should be space yup
so
pandas is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structures and operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
time series so
so after importing libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write like
we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with us
the first one is credits
this one
and the second one is movies one
movies one so don't worry you can get
these data set link in the description
box so let me write
here
credits
let's go data frame equals to PD dot
read
underscore CSV
here you have to give your location of
the data set
edits
dot CSV
the second one is movies
let's go data frame
this is for movie data frame PD dot
treat
USB
so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location movies
dot CSV
okay everything seems good
let me run this
yeah
so then
here PD is for the pandas Library read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and CSV is used for the type
of file which you want to read
so after this let's write code to see
the data set so we will write here
credits underscore DF
and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore
so this is our movie data set
so this is how our board data set look
like so here you can see three dots
this one and here also
this one
so we are unable to see our full data
set like what if we want like full a4803
rows
so at that case
we can write here
PD Dot set
underscore option
okay
and here we will write display
dot Max
underscore columns
this
and here we will write none
same for the rows PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
underscore rows
okay
none
let's run this
so now if we will write credits
underscore DF
it is running yeah
so now you can see your full data set
like full credit data set with 4803 rows
or four eight zero two rows because
there is
this is starting from zero that's why so
what about movies data set
okay wait running
it is still running you can see here
so here you can see the full data set
movie data set with 4802 rows
or if you want to see only five top rows
so you can write here
credits underscore DF dot head
so by this
only five top rows so from head you we
can see our five top rows and if we will
use tail instead of head we can see our
last five rows so here let me do with
the movies one
DF Dot tail
yeah
so here you can see 4798 row four seven
nine and Del four eight zero two so we
tell we can see our last five rows
so moving forward let's merge the credit
data set to movie data set because if we
will combine them the confusion will be
less and at the end it will be better
for us so we will write here movies
underscore
equals to movies
underscore data frame and credits
underscore DF
on
it okay T is small I guess yeah perfect
title
so let me do something something like
this
okay
it is saying data frame object is not
callable
edits underscore PF
okay why because
we haven't wrote merge here
now it will work
yeah perfect it's working so data is
merged let's see the number of rows and
column using share function so now we
have only one so movies underscore DF
dot shape
okay let's run it 4809 and 2 3 23 but if
we see here like in movies data set so
in movies data set here here yeah yeah
there are 20 and
in here we are four columns in credit
data set
so
like so you will be thinking that's why
not 24 why only 23 columns that is why
on title you can see here on title the
titles in both titles are same you can
see here
both titles are same
in both
okay let me show you like this
okay Avatar Pirates of the Caribbean
Spectra and so on here you can see avtar
pirates of the academy inspector and so
on
so that is why on title
written while merging so titles are same
so moving forward let's see our merge
data set
so we will write only movies
underscore data frame dot head
yeah
so our data is merged you can see
the last cast crew movie ID yeah you can
see here movie ID title are the same
they are most cast crew okay guys
let me give some more
for the better View
yeah
so you can see all Columns of credit
data set are added to movies one so
moving forward let's see another
function like
movies
underscore DF Dot info
so by this
yes you can see
so by this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information
so here you can see the all the
information is printed
okay
like columns name and the all null
values count and data types to like this
int object and
in which we are working most so after
this let's move forward and select some
main column in which you are working
most so we will write movies
underscore DF
equals to movies
underscore DF
score B
title
comma and another one is overview
if y
okay here we have to like this
yeah
so here we have to write John R
Jonah is complete and we will work on
what keywords keywords are the main
keywords okay keywords then
it will cast
then we will
we will do recommendation with the crew
as well
okay
so by running this let me see
our data again with seven okay okay
there is one error okay this is movie
the movie The Idea yeah not index okay
got it got it
why not Jonah
it's Jonas I guess
what it is it's John it's
that's why
it's Jonas okay
yeah so let's see our data again with
seven columns so I will write so I will
write
here movies underscore DF
dot head
here
right so you can see only our we have
like movies ID same title overview
genres keywords cash and crew only
so here you you can see the selected
columns okay so let's move forward and
once again let's see the info again like
movies
underscore TF Dot
info is come with selected columns and
let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that four thousand eight zero three
values are filled or not so what we will
do it we will see how many missing
values are present there so
here we will write like movies
underscore DF dot is null
dot sum
not like this
yeah perfect
so the function data frame is null this
one is null dot sum dot sum Returns the
number of missing values in the data set
so here you can see overview have three
missing values
so what we can do is we can write here
movies
underscore DF
DF
Dot
drop n a
this
equals to
true
okay
we will run it with sayings okay words
documents
was it true okay fine
third underscore drop in it and yeah it
will not create an issue so if you sat
in place equals to true the drop any
method will modify your data frame
directly that means that if you set in
place equals to true the drop any will
drop all missing values from your
original data set let's move forward and
see
movies
underscore DF
Dot
duplicated
so the duplicate method returns a series
with true on false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so
here let me run this first
so here we are we are getting 0. y 0 so
if you are like thinking there is no
true or false return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without some
okay let me copy from here yeah and I
will run this so
here you can see
false false false in whole data set
so some will combine them and return you
a value at the end zero represent false
itself
so we need to not need this so we will
write something else
so moving forward let me write First
movies
underscore TF dot I location
0
Dot johnnets
let me run this
so the I log function this one ilock
function
first let me do something like this
it will go up okay huh
okay so from ilock function in Python is
defined in the pandas module that helps
us to select a specific row or column
from the data set
using the ilock method in Python we can
easily retrieve any particular value
from a row or column by using index
value so here zeroth position line is
coming
which is here you can see
so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this PSI
physician
this one science fiction yeah so this is
because I am giving here Jonah that is
why you can see here
see id28 name action name something
something like that okay
so
let's import something called ASG
abstract Syntax for tree
so this is one of the major Library
import AST
let me run this import is a class
defined is the AST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so
so an abstract syntax tree or just
syntax tree is a tree representation of
the of the abstract syntactic structure
of text written in a formal language
each node of the trade denotes a
construct occurring in the text
so let's convert some like literal to
object and append them so here I will
write Def
convert
obj object
like l
equals to
blank array
for I in
St Dot
turtle
bit
if we
Which object
okay
l dot append
return
here we are converting is like here is a
convert is a function and L is the array
to append by using for Loop we can
append them to name so let me write code
then I will explain like what is
happening so let me write full code so
movies
underscore TF
like
Donuts
okay
because your movies
Donuts
and then dot apply
what
so then movies underscore TF
then I will write keywords
let's do movies
underscore DF
keywords
lie
this code DF Dot
so if we will see our old data set in
that like we will see old data set in
that journal and that's keyword this
keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a message retrieving them so by
using AST Library we just convert them
to the normal one like title so got it
guys so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
abbreviating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
type of questions regarding any code or
something
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's convert cash to
and like same as previous way like like
this only
so what we will do here we will write f
convert
them
here I am using
so L equals to
counter equals to zero
St
dot literal
we
if counter
does not
equals to 3
then
l dot
Dot
dot append okay then here I have to
write I
to name
okay
counter
equals to 1.
if you want to write like count as
equals to counter plus one it is like
both the same
else
click
done
l
so let me run this let me run this
okay so after this small code we have to
assign the values like
we are doing it for Costner so movies
okay moves
let's score DF then cast
there's two movies
underscore DF
asked
Dot
reply
convert
everything seems good
so let's see the changes are visible or
not so we will write here movies
underscore TF dot hat
you can ignore this like this is nothing
so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and journal so like
let's do for the Creo too
so like we are converting you can say in
a structured way
so let's do for the crew one two so let
me put some
yeah
so here we will add depth like fetch
which is nothing like a function name as
director
obj
colon l equals to
or i n s t Dot literal
obj
if
I
like top
equals to
we can say director
so then
l dot append
l dot append
um
dot append to the same name
but
return
okay capital l
so we have to again write that movies
video
equals to movies
in crew
lie
h
just remember fetch director is a
function name let's see changes
so here I have to write movies then
press enter
so yeah crew is all set so
changes are visible and data is looking
good so what we like if I want to see
the first movie Avatar overview this
like this dot dot dot so I have to write
here
like movies
overview
Overview at zeroth
place
so yeah
so this is a full overview of Avatar
movie like let me read for this in this
2017 Century uh paraplegic Marine is
dispatched and blah blah blah blah and
civilization
so moving forward that what we want to
recommend movie in the basis of overview
genre keyword cars so for that we need a
separate separate words like in the then
22nd century alone
so if you will see in other columns all
the words are separated but like here if
you will see all the words are separated
like action is separated Adventure is
separated fantasy it's separated
so
there is a long sentence in this this
one in the overview one these are long
sentence
so it's difficult to recommend from this
so what we are going to do is well we
will separate them like like other
columns so here we will write
movies
overview
let's do movies
and overview
and Dot apply
lie my bad sorry
then Lambda
colon X
Dot
split
error so let's see the results so movies
yeah you can see in the Saturn so now
you can see all the words are separated
by comma so now it will easy to match
overview to recommend a particular movie
so moving forward so what we are going
to do is if there is a two word and
space between there so we are going to
remove that space so here you can see
science fiction are separate separate
okay so we are going to re like remove
this one this is space
so let's write code for that
so here I will write like
overview is already done so we will do
not do for that so let's write code for
the rest columns
so here I have to write
movies
like
genres
for some movies
and again
Jonas
or apply
Lambda
X
I dot replace
Ma
to no space
oh it seems good
then I have to write for everywhere so
for I in x
it's 4 I in x 4 I in x
movies genres equals to movie genres dot
apply Lambda X
I don't replace this to this for
same Squad
so let's copy paste this see
one for keywords and one for cast and
crew
it's
people
asked
first
that you
that's the same so let me run this
okay no error seems good so let's see
the changes so movies
so now you can see the science fiction
space is gone like here is science
fiction space is there
now science fiction space is gone
so like uh okay
let's move forward and create one new
column name as tag and put all the
column data in a particular column
okay let me do first yeah let me write
movies
this is a column one column name equals
to movies
then first we will put overview
Plus movies
and Jonas
and movies
and what we have to give keywords
keywords
then again
movies
then
asked
let me run this
okay
so let's see the data frame uh movies
okay still coming so like there is one
problem I guess
yeah no no no
so here you can see all the data is
merged in a under attack column yes you
can see like in the second sorry blah
blah blah so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code
or anything just put as in comment or
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution okay so I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or like any
question just put as in comment our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution
so from here let's create a new data
frame
okay
so let me create new data frame because
now we don't need this overview car
screw Joiner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like attack column so we will
write here new
DF equals to movies
so
like movies we need movie ID
new data frame we need movie ID comma we
need Title
and we have everything in tag column
text column so we need tax column
okay let's run this let's see our new
data frame
so this is our new data look likes with
only three columns like a movie ID title
and tags so here you can see array
brackets like this this area brackets
so
we are gonna remove them so we will do
what we will write here we will write
new
data frame
that n tags
equals to
new
data frame
tax
dot apply
Lambda
X
then I will give space
dot join
themes good everything is okay okay fine
yeah
so let's see the results so
we will write a new underscore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the 0th index intact column like this
dot dot in this
okay for that we have to write here
a new
data frame
tax
we did it before like for the overviewer
so you have to yeah
so this is the whole data in the first
like first index zeroth index so some
part of the overview like from
civilization and some are you can see
this action Advantage fantasy science
fiction these are some like genres
and
like here you can see like these are
some Crews members
and
yeah like Sam Worthington like there are
some cast crew okay
so like moving forward like what we are
going to do is just make them in lower
case for the better prediction like
something in capital and something like
smaller so let's make it to
lowercase so new underscore DF
tax
equals to new underscore DF
tax
dot apply
it's got an X
dot lower
okay
don't worry about this error
let's see the result uh new underscore
DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in small case or you can say
lowercase moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so like let me write first
from SK learn
Dot feature
instruction
feature extraction okay cool
dot text
import
count
vectorizer
CV equals to
count
riser
underscore
features
features
equals to
5000.
oh
words
equals to
English
and this
yeah
so count vectorizer okay there is a
I cannot import count vectorizer from
SQL and from user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital
okay guys so he V is capital yeah so no
error so count vectorizer is a great
tool provided by the scikit-learn
library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count
of each word that occurs in the entire
text so
let me write something CV Dot
with underscore
transform
f
X like dot to array
shape
okay
so the fit method like learns a
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are words separated by spaces and
like punctuation so that Maps e single
token to a position in the output Matrix
so here CVS are like here CV is a
counter vectorizer so let's convert into
Vector to array so for this we have to
write vectors
vectors equals to CV dot fit
okay then transform
X
ing
so here we have to write
Dot
to array
yeah then we have to write
vector
its vectors
yeah you can see Vector 2 array all the
zeros
okay so moving forward let's get the
feature Name by writing
okay so we will write here
Lian LAN
CV dot get
feature
names
usernames okay then bracket
yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code whatever it is so
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so let's import some major Library which
is import
nltk
so what is nltk the natural language
toolkit nltk is a platform used for
building python programs that work with
human language
for applying in a statical network
language processing NLP it contained
text processing libraries for
tokenization parsing classification
stemming tagging and semantic reasoning
so moving forward like from let me write
first from
and
ltk
dot stem
dot Porter
import
ER
yes equals to
quarter
I mean is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
or to the roots of words known as Alama
stemming is important in natural
language understanding nlu and natural
language processing NLP
so here like I have to write
so here I will write def stem
to text
y
equals to
or
I in
text Dot split
y Dot append
s dot stem
done
or join
why
so let's apply this timing to attack
column so here we will write new DF
X
equals to
new
if
tag
dot apply
um
so let's import a cosine similarity from
SK learn so we will write from SK learn
dot matrices
Dot pairwise
import
cosine
underscore see me clarity
okay it seemed good from SQL and
mattresses
metrics sorry Matrix Dot pairwise it is
[Music]
pairwise import cosine similarity okay
let's run this no error so cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two factors
I repeat cosine similarity measures the
similarity between two vectors of an
inner product space it is measured by
the cosine of the angle between two
vectors and determines whether two
vectors are pointing in roughly the same
direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will write
cosine
underscore see me
clarity
vectors
so these all are the vector present
let's see the cosine similarity Vector
column and rho using space
so here I will write cosine
let's go see similarity
vectors
dot shape
so it's still running you can see here
yeah
so 4806 rows and four eight zero six
columns are there let's assign variable
similarity to this
okay so let's similarity
will write like this so let it goes to
cosine
similarity
is underscore here
I did this because we don't have to
write always this long sentence
a long keyword you can say
so moving forward let's see First Column
like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
clarity
0
Dot
shape
4806 okay so let's move forward and
let's create some like sorted list so
for that sort it
okay
paste
enumerate
spelling is fine
uh okay one more like Simi laity
similarity
zero
where I have to write reverse
equals to true
comma key
equals to Lambda
colon
x dot capital x x
to write one
one colon six
seems good yeah
so the enumerate function in Python
converts a data collection object into
an enumerate object enumerate returns an
object that contains a counter as a key
for each value with an object making
item within a collection easier to
access so finally let's create the
recommend function to check the movie
recommendation system
okay
so
so let's write here d f
recommend
we
X
so new
DF
in the TF
title
movie
X
zero
tenses
versus similarity
and movie
yeah so movies
list equals to sorted
numerate
r80 number it
distances
reversed
was to
true
keyword
sorry key only okay
equals to Lambda
is colon X
1
and
6.
or I in movies
list
Dot ilock
I
zero
zero dot title we because we need Title
only
so yeah it seems good okay
so finally that like time is game
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can comment in the chat
section so I can check
so let me write first recommend
recommend for movie
Avatar
okay
so here you can see the recommendation
system is working fine so Titan a DOT e
small soldier Independence Day are the
recommendation for the movie after so
let me check for the another one
recommend
like four
one of my favorite movie Iron Man
so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron Man
3 Avengers Age of Ultron Captain America
and the Avengers are just
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
Liars
liar
things going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is
Captain America Civil War
let me copy from here only
yeah you can see the Captain America the
First Avenger the Winter Soldier Iron
Man 3 age of ultron's The Avengers
intimate analysis sometime known as
opinion mining
is a technique used in natural language
processing NLP to determine the
emotional undertone of a document
this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept
text is mined for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
tools for sentiment analysis assist
businesses in extracting information
from unstructured unorganized language
found in online sources like emails blog
posts support tickets webchats forums
and comments algorithm use rule-based
automatic or hybrid technology to
replace manual data processing while
automatic system use machine learning to
learn from their data rule based system
execute sentiment analysis using
predetermined
lexicon-based rules combining the two
method result in hybrid sentiment
analysis
sentiment analysis or opinion mining can
extract the subject opinion holder and
polarity or the degree of positivity and
negative
from the text and identify sentiment
additionally other Scopes including
document paragraph sentence and sub
sentence level can be used for sentiment
analysis after seeing what is sentiment
analysis let's discuss some types of
sentiment analysis so the first one is
fine grain sentiment analysis by
segmenting sentiment each phrase or
clause in a sentence is broken down and
examined in relationship to the others
simply said you can tell who review a
product and what topics a person is
specifically discuss in their feedback
and the second one is emotion detection
instead of identifying positivity and
negativity emotion detection recognized
particular emotions example could
include shock rage grief frustration and
happiness and the third one is intent
based analysis in addition to identify
opinions in a text the intent based
analysis also identifies behaviors
for instance a frustrated online comment
about changing a battery can motivate
customer care to get in touch to address
that particular problem
and the last one is expect based
analysis collects the precise component
that is being mentioned either favorably
or unfavorably
for instance a client May write in a
product review that the battery life is
too short the system will then respond
that the battery life is the main
complaint and not the product as a whole
so after seeing types of sentiment
analysis let's see some application of
sentiment analysis
organization can employ sentiment
analysis Technologies for a number of
purpose such as
determining brand popularity reputation
and awareness at a particular period or
overtime
customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target Market
and the fifth one is determining the
effectiveness of a marketing effort
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answers in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong so
the question is is text analytics also
refers to as text mining
I'm repeating again is text analytics
also refers to as text mining the
options are true
or false
so let us know your answer in comment
section below or in chat section
so I am starting timer of one minute
just type your answer in comment section
or in chat section
do let me know your answers so I'm
starting timer of one minute
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
so the question is is stacked Analytics
also refers to as text mining
35 seconds are left
do let me know your answers I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
the live session exciting
do one
20 seconds left
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so time up guys
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
okay now let's move to our programming
part to perform sentiment analysis using
Amazon Customer data set
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we'll write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
okay it's Jupiter notebook
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select
new python file
it's loading
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some bunch of
major libraries of python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
the first one is numpy
so first I will write numpy import numpy
that's NP
and Pi is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely
numpy stands for numerical python
so the next one is pandas
so I will write here
import
pandas
as PD
so pandas is a software Library written
for a Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structures and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
after that we will import
nltk
so the natural language toolkit nltk is
a Python Programming environment for
creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing libraries
so after that
we will import from an ltk
Dot
sentiment
dot Vader
import
sentiment
HD
analyzer
okay there is no column
yeah
so the Lexicon and rule-based sentiment
analysis tool Vader weather means
valence aware dictionary and essential
reasoning
is a customized precisely two sentiments
expressed on social media Vader makes
use of variety of a sentiment lexicon is
a collection of lexical elements such as
words
that are often classified as either
positive or negative depending on their
semantic orientation
Vader not only informs us of the
positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each score
so the next one is import
re
python re module fully supports regular
expression similar to those in Pearl if
a regular expression compilation or use
error occurs the re modules raises the
expression re
two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered
so re means regular expressions
so the next one is
from
X blob
import
blob
okay
so a python two or three package called
text blob is used to process textual
data it offers a straightforward API to
explore typical natural language
processing NLP
tasks like part of speech tagging noun
phrase extraction sentiment analysis
classification translation and more
so the next one is
import
words
from
word
cloud
avoid Cloud commonly refers to as a tag
cloud is an image of words popular words
and phrases are highlighted using Cloud
creators depending on their frequency
and importance
they give you immediate straightforward
visual insights that can Inspire more
through analysis
and the next one is import
C bone
as
SNS
yeah
so like an open source python Library
based on matplotlib is called C bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization
with data frames and the pandas Library
c-bond function with ease
so the next one is import
matplotlib
Dot
Pi plot
as PLT
okay yeah seems good
for Python and its numerical expression
numpy matplotlib is a cross platform
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it presents
a strong open source substitute for
Matlab the API is for matplotlib allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications
and the next one is
import
links
c u f f l i n k s as
CF
perfect
another python module called cufflink
links plotly with pandas so that charts
can be easily created on data frames in
essence it function like a plugin
so next inline
at plot lip
add plot clip
so you can enable inline plotting by
using the magic function percentage math
problem inline which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below
the cell where you plotting commands are
entered similar to a Jupiter notebook it
offers back-end interactivity in front
ends so next we will import
what you can like we can import okay
from
Earthly dot offline
import
init underscore notebook
underscore mode
comma I plot
yeah
init underscore notebook
notebook
mode
who gets through yeah
dot go
underscore
offline
so
yeah in order to display the plot inside
the notebook you need to initiate
broadly notebook mode as follows like
this
keep rest of the script as it is like it
and run the notebook cell by pressing
you can shift press enter graph will be
displayed offline inside the notebook so
basically it is used for the offline
graphing you can see okay so next we
will import
um plotly
dot subplots subplots are important
import
make underscore subplot
okay yeah
the non-leaf nodes in this figure schema
are represented by a hierarchy of python
classes that was automatically
constructed and is found in the plotly
dot graph objects which is normally
imported as go
these class instance are refers to as
graph object the plotly defined
fundamental classes
okay
so here we will import some like
warnings you can say
like to get not error
so we will import let me give a line
space
import
warning
warnings yeah
warnings
dot filter
warning
ignore
warnings dot one
and
this uh like will not show
and let me add something PD
dot set
option
display Dot Max underscore
plums
okay import
words from word cloud
okay there is an error let me check
what's the error
okay import
this
word cloud
from word cloud
it's capital
and W is also capital
here will be capital
that it would be small only
from word cloud
okay my bad here one from word cloud
from word cloud
import word cloud
okay
yeah seems good
so wherever we
yeah or in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to display warning messages
utilize the wand
found in the warning module the python
built-in class inspection is a subclass
of the warning module which is used to
display warning messages import warnings
okay for seeing full data every single
columns like
okay there is error c bond
no modulus C1 so
s will be small
got it
okay inline
this only live
something like that a line
okay any errors no
I guess no error
okay
yeah for seeing full data like every
single Columns of PD so here we are
using this PD dot set option
so we can use for it
so moving forward let's import data set
so for importing data set we will write
here
uh
like DF equals to PD Dot
read
CSV
okay
add data set name
so
you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for that
so let me run this
okay
so like here is PD is for pandas Library
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read
so let's see our data
so here I will write DF Dot hat
yeah
so
if you want to like if you want to see
top five rows of your data set you can
use head and if you want to uh like see
five rows of your data set you can use
tail insert instead of head this one
okay so this is our data set with only
five rows
if you want to see full data set you can
like from starting from 0 and ending it
four nine one four rows okay
four nine one one five rows and 12
columns
it
so let me give something like this for
the pattern visual
yeah
okay so moving ahead let's sort this
Wilson bound column to ascending order
for better analysis so I am talking
about this Wilson lower bound column
this one for it's not zero zero zero
like you know all the rows so let me
show you
so here you have to write like DF equals
to DF dot sort
values
Wilson
spelling should be correct
lower
bound
I will make it to ascending order
ascending
sorry descending order so
BF dot drop
named
unnamed
colon 0
okay
in place
and base equals to true
comma X is
equals to 1
okay so let's see our data
so here you can see the data is sorted
in s
in as ascending order okay
so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
draft method eliminate the specified
column when the column axis is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row axis is
supplied
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any queries or like any
queries regarding any code or there is
something question till here just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
okay
so moving forward let's make a function
for missing values
so
okay
so I will write here like DF
missing
values
analysis
okay it's def a function we use DF
columns
was true
col
for columns
for
for
col
n d f Dot
columns
DF
column
is null
dot sum
greater than zero
underscore Miss
equals to
DF
underscore columns
let's go
dot sum
but with DOT sort values
sort underscore values
like in ascending
ascending
ascending equals to
true
okay
like some
if you like this and this
that's fine I guess
yeah so here I will write ratio
underscore equals to
DF n a underscore columns
underscore
Dot
additional
same thing that sum
divided by
F dot shape
level
100
or sort
values
ending
was true true
fine
okay okay
that means okay and the TF part
get sort values because you're sending
true fine
so
here we will write missing
underscore DF equals to PD
Dot concat
P dot round
issue
underscore comma
two
you're perfect
where access will be 1.
okay
is
equals to
that will give like
total where I will write missing values
missing
values
okay
comma
ratio
underscore DF equals to PD
dot data frame
score DF
okay so let me return
PF
let's create one more function for like
check data frame so DF
yeah underscore data frame
okay
it equals to five
comma tail
equals to
5.
so here I will write print
okay
yeah
Dot Center
comma
again for row Sprint
pose
belly braces
okay
dot format
s
what format
yeah
dot shape
you know
so for column Sprint
or shape
paint
and types like of
types of data
Dot
Center
same as like that 82
comma
end
DF dot d types
Center
just printing this is like you will see
don't worry
just stay with me you will see the
beautiful result
okay print
values
print missing values uh analysis and
cases like DF
okay
then again
you did
values
like there's many how many duplicate
values are there
so dot same for the center
gee
one more
again this one
end
we have dot duplicated
don't worry I will explain you like line
by line
just stay with me let me write the whole
code
first print
tiles
like I am printing multiple of things
so just be with me
Dot
82
comma
F Dot
one tile
zero five
comma
one
okay
check
data frame
I'm hoping like there will be no error
yeah
so you can see now like multiple
information regarding data set is
printed
so this shape is for like how many rows
and columns present in the data set like
in types you can say like every column
type like object
N64 float 64 and many more are like
present so like you can see review text
is like object and their differences N64
and Wilson lower bound is float 64.
okay so total missing values
so total missing values are like uh
1 from here and one from here like one
inform reviewer name and other is from
reviewer text
and like there is no duplicated values
in our data set
and here you can see so like after that
quantize a quantile defines a particular
part of the data set that is a quantile
determines how many values in the
distribution are above or below a
certain limit
special quantiles are the like quartile
quarter and you can say quintile that
the fifth one and the percentile which
is from 100th okay so quantile is for
like quarter
or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 83 82 and this for
this purpose
for making this something look cool
that is why
okay and
so moving forward
let's see unique values and in each
column
okay so I will add
check
Plus
frame
unique
f equals to PD
Dot data
frame
variable
variable
the frame
columns comma
classes
colon
data frame
I
will write like an unique
unique
uue
or
I in
data frame
Dot
columns
okay like and unique
you
or DF equals to
dot sort
values
classes
comma ascending
equals to
false
okay
and unique
underscore DF equals to n
unique
F dot reset
index
drop equals to
true
return
and unique
q-u-e and unique
let's go DF
check underscore class
which one DF
so let me run this first
yeah it's running you can see here
okay there is an error classes
okay
check class DF
is saying that
this is
kses Capital C Small
let me run now
yeah
so here you can see the every column
having unique values are sorted in
descending order like review tags have
like more unique values
so it come first and then review your
name review time date difference Wilson
lower bound score average then goes to
overall
okay moving forward let's do some
categorical variable analysis for
overall yes so this will be like amazing
something amazing is going to be
happened
so
constraints equals to so I am giving
here like some
color values so
B 3 4
d
2 2.
E B zero zero C
okay
so you can change you can like write
whatever you want color
s
mistake
right hashtag here
hashtag
three come on
it's done
0 C
9 to EB
0
3
and then d
you like five right
okay so d f let's make function Okay
small d f
categorical
variable
okay
DF comma
column
okay categorical variable summary yeah
perfect
so let's make some figures so make
subplots
rows
equals to
1
comma calls
question two
let me write from here like subplot
ALS
equals to
count plot
like one for percentage
percentage
okay
so specs speech
equals to
a like
type
colon
colon
that's why
okay
same type
colon here
domain
we got dot at
and then Trace
Dot
bar
one bar and one that pie chart okay
why
equals to DF
columns
column name
values Dot
to list
or X you can click string
yeah Str
I
or I
in
yeah
column
name
dot value
Dot counts
X
equals to DF
column name
dot value
counts and then bracket
dot values
dot to list
okay
go for text
font
the size should be
14 is enough I guess
is to column
underscore name
X position
so I'm doing for like making chart so
stay with me to see that amazing chart
okay
so show Legend
s to take
colors
goes to constraints
so these are the like colors so I'm
giving here value like very variable
name
because
constraints
comma line
equals to
left
hashtag
DB
e
6 AC
comma
just one
Okay small
okay let me just like go over through
everything is correct or not for the
column name
will accounts index yeah it's fine
text equals to TF column name
dot value
counts
dot values
to to list okay
text font equals to take size then okay
14 size is enough
name equals to column name and text
position equals to auto
and show Legend false and Mark
detect like color equals to constant
okay fine line equals to color
and this yeah this okay
cool
o equals to one
comma column equals to one
that seems good
like for pie chart we will make figure
dot at
so this is done for the like line chart
not line chart that bar chart and this
I'm doing for the pie chart okay
Trace
go Dot
pi
f
columns
column name
is
values
equals to DF
again that column name
what value
count
counts
and Dot values
text font
because you take
yeah size
I will prefer 18 is enough
position
like Auto is fine
so Legend
let's do no need of Legend false
m equals to column name
and your column name
colors
because to constants
will go to one
one column equals to like in second
okay you will see and you will get to
know don't worry
so if we got dot update
layout
equals to
column
0.9
and 5
come on
X
r
should be on centered
and Y anchor
Beyond top
let equals to
tally
a
I plot
figure
let me run this okay like
call equals to 2
now let's see the chart of like column
overall one so we will write here
categorical
okay
variable
variable
summary
and then data frame name DF
comma overall
okay let's run this
okay it's loading here
it's loading
yeah
you can see this is this is our bar plot
and this is our pie chart
so
like this is overall
uh from overall you can say that column
so like percentage bar and that bar plot
so this is how our like pie chart and
bar chart looks like I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code
okay like any code any sort of code
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you at the correct
solution
so moving forward our goal is to rank
the com comments by the sentiment
analysis so we don't get hung up on the
other details I have sorted this data
set according to certain rules before
so moving forward we want to clean our
data so let's see the sample data for
cleaning
so DF Dot
review
text
okay dot
hat
let me run this so
so this is our sample data looks like so
let's see like data full data for this
okay let me see for
or this I guess okay
or like any particular row you can say I
can take okay
so I will write review
underscore example
example
equals to DF
Dot
review
text I will take a random 2031 I guess
Okay so
review
underscore example
so this is like at two zero three one
there is one review text
okay so in that the whole data is here
like uh like so my lovely wife bought me
a Samsung Galaxy Tab for father this
this this
like to find the exact model number this
is a long you know command
I got the this this it works like a
charm okay
so
after seeing this data what we're gonna
do is like we will clean it from
punctuation and numbers using regex
regex what regular expression okay so
here I will write
review underscore example
sample okay
okay
equals to re dot sub
and what I will do is
okay I will explain
don't worry
small rate
to capital a
to Z
okay
comma then space
comma G view underscore example
exam
but
sorry
yeah
review
so here we used re for regular
expression
okay and
so all the punctuation and numbers are
removed from particular data
so let me check first
okay this A to Z then A to Z okay fine
so like all the punctuation and numbers
are removed from particular data I will
now convert the texture to all lowercase
our machine learning algorithm
recognized words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lowercase so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with the
capital letter as a different word so
what I will do is
here I will write review
scample
sample
equals to G View
again example
dot lower
I will split
split
okay
yeah example
so here you can see we have converted
all the words in the lowercase letter by
using lower function and why they are
coming in new lines because we are
splitting them using split function okay
if you see only did lowercase for single
row like we did for the like two zero I
guess two zero three one okay yeah so
let's make all rows same in lowercase so
I will write here RT
equals to Lambda
X
we will
Str
X
for DF
U
text
is capital text
DF
View
text
text
okay equals to DF
View
just
yeah dot lower
you have done
add
see all the data is in like lowercase
so I printed just top 10 rows and in
like in reviews text column all the are
in the lowercase now so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or question till here like any code just
put as in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution and if
you need this full code you can comment
down below okay
so now the time has come to do sentiment
analysis because all the data is sorted
so what
will I write here
let me
do it little bit up
yeah
so I will write
from
yeah
from Vader
sentiment
dot Vader
equipment
report
sentiment
intensity
analyzer
if
polarity
subjectivity
is subjectivity
so
DF
View
text
dot apply
da
XT PD
dot series
text
blob
and again text
Dot
like sentiment
let me run for Loop for index
comma row
in DF
G View
text
but item
items
for you
anti-man
density
analyzer
or polarity
scores
row
foreign
score
or neutral I will write score
f for positive
if
this is something crazy if negative is
greater than positive
then DF dot location
index
comma
demand
equals to
negative
negative
yes Dan
I'll see if
positive is greater than negative
then in this case
d f Dot
log
index
comma
sentiment
first two
positive
P capital
else
F dot LSC
X
intimate
let's do
neutral
yeah
so like this is for sentiment analysis
and text block
this thing like text blob
this blob okay it's blocked
a text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive
or negative or neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1 the closer to 1
the more positive the closer to zero is
more negative
okay let me run this it will take
a little bit time
because this sentiment okay it is
getting error
like model Panda has no attribute series
okay which one
text boxing
next sentiment
okay here what is the thing s is capital
let me run now
it is executing
like fit for a while wait
so it will take time to run because like
because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer
it take times
again sentiment intensity
analyzer okay spelling mistake again
y index index is not defined
sorry again
index
it will run I guess because everything
seems good
negative positive and this else
still loading so I have to wait like for
like two minutes more I guess
still loading guys
I take time
sentiment intensity analyzer
so let me tell you again sentiment
analysis like this text blob
text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity
so polarity indicates your mood that is
whether it is positive it is negative or
it is it will be neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1 the closer to one
the more
positive the closer to zero more
negative okay
I guess it's still
running
so
it will take time so let me write code
for that 20 interpretation I repeat
moving forward let's identify the 20
interpretation now we can include the
positive negative and neutral status of
the command
okay
then DF
DF
sentiment
what's equals to
positive
ought
lose
Sun
lower
ending
equals to
false
yeah
dot head
it's five
if I will run it may
give errors to me because it's still
running
still running here it's still loading
so let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and neutral
Okay so
categorical
variable
summary
TF
event
yeah
it came like this because of this wait I
will tell you
yeah so here you can see the pie chart
distributed in negative positive and
neutral emotions
okay or you can say ratings and here you
can see the bar chart also what is loan
prediction system first and proceed
further for the same a mechanism called
loan prediction system gives you a way
to apply for loans and receive
notification when they are approved in
accordance with the data provided by the
applicant the system notifies the
applicant of the loans available so here
is one question for you guys I will give
you one minute for this you can comment
or you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answer given
by you are right or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you I will give you one
minute for this you can comment or you
can give your answer in the chat section
so I can see if the answer is given by
you are right or wrong so the question
is which keyword is used for function in
Python language Option 1 python option
two def
Austin c f u and C option D Define
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below Okay so
I am starting off timer 1 minutes
type your answer in the comment section
or in the chat section do let me know
your answers please I kindly ask that
everyone take part in this to make this
live session exciting so I'm starting
the timer of one minute
which keyword is used for function in
Python language Option 1 function option
two def option C Punk option D Define
which keyword is used for function in
Python language
47 kin remaining
30 seconds let us know your answer in
the comment section below
this is the easy one which keyword is
used for function in Python language
function def Funk or Define
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this exciting
five second more
yeah after that allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receives one
so now let's move to our programming
part to implement loan approval
prediction system
so first we will open a command prompt
to write a command to open Jupiter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
Python 3 file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us creating a loan approval
prediction system
so here I will write import
numpy
as NP
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the second one is
port
pandas
as PD panda is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis
in particular it offers data structure
and operations for manipulating
numerical tables and Time series
and the third one is import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
so Matt plotly Python scripts can be
used to create 2D graphs and plots using
the matplotlab module with features to
control line Styles font attributes
formatting access and other features it
offers a module called Pi plot that
makes things simple for plotting
so the fourth one is
import
C bone
s
and S
so C bone an open source python Library
based on matplotlip is called c-bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization with data frames and
the pandas Library C1 function with ease
so there is one more
like ROM
Escalon
port
svm
so after importing libraries let's move
forward and import data set so DF equals
to
PD dot read
underscore CSV
so
dot CSC
you can download this data set from the
description box below
so yeah
so data set is imported let's see our
data set so we will write DF dot head
here
yeah
here you can see we have data set of top
five rows so basically head is used for
showing first five rows of the data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show the last five rows of the
data set
so let's move forward and use info
function to see the information about
the data set
okay so here we will write
DF dot info
so the data frame information is printed
by the info method the data includes the
total number of columns their labels
data kinds memory use range index and
the number of cells in each column that
is non-null values note that the info
method does indeed print the information
okay so here you can see loan ideas
object then this applicant income is N64
then co-applicant income is float
so normal values like this
so
we know all the columns names data types
and information let's move forward and
see missing values in the data set so
for that we will use here I will write
DF dot is null
then basis
dot sum
yeah dot sum the data set total number
of missing values is written via sum
Escape rows in the data set that have
missing values as a straightforward
solution for the missing value data
so we have missing values in loan ID 0
gender is 13 then loan amount is 22
self-employed is 32
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code so just put us in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or any question
related to python just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
moving forward we will create one more
column
that is loan amount log using loan
amount detail and then we will display a
histogram for that
okay so let me do first for the better
view I can do this
yeah
I will write here DF
tone
amount
let's go log
yeah
plus two NP
DOT log
if
now we will do DF
loan
amount underscore log
dot hist
for the histogram then pins I will take
20.
numpy.log
a mathematical function that helps user
to calculate natural logarithms of X
where X belongs to all the input array
elements you can see histograms it's
looking fine let's see the null values
in our new column
so I will write here
PF dot is null
dot sum
so here you can see in loan amount log
there are 22 missing values
so moving forward let's create one more
column name total income in this we will
add two columns applicant income and
co-applicant income and we will display
histogram for the same
EF like
total income
a equals to DF
applicant income
and we will add one more data from TF
that is
go applicant
f
total income
underscore log
pursue NP Dot
log
DF
capital
done
TF
well income
underscore log
dot hist
equals to 20.
yeah
so here you can see
histogram of the total income log moving
forward let's fill those null values in
all the respective columns so here for
that we will write
DF
gender
dot 12 n a
DF
gender
dot mode
0
comma in place
to true
and
what I will do I will copy from here
change here gender to married
they're also married
and here for self employed
and I will do self
deployed
to for dependent
just everything will be same so here I
will add DF Dot
loan amount
equals to
DF Dot
loan amount
dot fill any
PF Dot loan amount
dot mean
so here I will write instead of this I
will copy from here
and paste it here
yeah
let's go log
that Alice is small
so here I will write again that we can
take it from here
change column name
to loan
mount
um
on
amount
um
edit underscore history
again
credit underscore
history
so here I will write DF Dot is null
sum
it's it's worth giving error
same self employed
okay what the issue is that is capital
okay
again
dependent
okay
okay it's dependence
okay
yeah
so there is no missing values now
what we're gonna do is we will select
some specific columns and rows for the
training and testing
so for that I will write here
x equals to
dot I log
dot r
oh
in column 11
comma 13 colon 15.
dot values
y equals to
d f Dot
I log
then colon command 12
Dot
values
let me see the X values
okay so main no these are the X values
and let me see the Y values
okay so the I log function in Python is
defined in the pandas module that helps
us to select a specific row a column
from the data set using the ilock method
in Python we can easily retrieve any
particular value from a row or column by
using index values
so moving forward let's see the
percentage of missing genders from the
data set and we will do it for many
other columns
okay
so it if it will be 0 so it will be
great for us so we will write print
percent
of missing
gender
is
percent
to
f
sin
and we will write this
EF
and gender column
dot is null
dot sum
f
dot shape
zero
multiply by 100.
it is saying function object has no
attributes sum
okay why
because
here
percent of missing gender is zero great
so like so moving forward we will see
number of people who take loan as a
group by gender
okay so for that we will write print
numbers like of people
who take loan as
group
by gender
for that
print
DF
sender
dot value
counts
CNS dot count
plot
x equals to
sender
comma
data equals to DF
palette
goes to
set one you can use either set two
either set three
so let me see okay so
here you can see like mail is 502 female
are one one two you can see the bar plot
so the number of observation in each
category bins are displayed using bars
using the count plot technique the
following parameters are accepted by the
procedure and are listed below this
parameter accepts optional variables
names for data or vector data inputs for
long form data plotting so moving
forward we will do for the same
like number of people who take a loan
Group by marital status
so what I will do I will just copy from
here
and I will change it to here
so I will write
metal
s
and the guys were married
here I have to write the
eight
so here you can see
like four zero one
res like n213 I know
okay so moving forward we will see
number of people who tend loan Group by
dependents
so same what I will do I will paste it
here
I will just change the name here
dependent
change to here
so here you can see the dependence and
the Y label is the count so like 0r 360
102 101 and 51. and many more so moving
forward we will see number of people who
take loan group as a self-employed
okay for that what we have to do is
you have to just change names
e is capital here
okay let's see the graph so moving
forward we will see number of people who
take loan Group by loan amount
for that I have to write here
wait let me make a better visibility
yeah
so
as a loan amount
capital
yeah
here you can see
paragraph
so at the end we will see the number of
people who take loan Group by the credit
history
okay
so I will write here
same
as
credit history
that is history
three
credit underscore
history
okay
yeah so here you can see 525 and this 89
So based on my assessment we don't have
any missing values in the data set now
so moving forward let's import
scikit-learn library for training and
testing data set
so here I will write
from
sqln dot model
underscore
selection
code
train
underscore test underscore split
so I have like
train
comma X
test comma y
train comma y
test
okay
so here I will write
train
underscore test underscore split
X comma y
comma test
underscore size
equals to 0.2
random
state
equals to zero
on SK
learn
Dot pre-processing
processing
import
label
encoder
okay so level
score x equals to level
encoder
SK learn
but in my bed
X is not defined
here we have
is the one of the most robust library
for machine learning
it is open source and built upon numpy
sci-fi and matplotlib it provides a
range of tools of machine learning and
statical modeling
and train test split function of this SK
learn model selection package in Python
splits arrays or matrices into random
subsets for train and test data
and label encoder and code label with a
value between 0 and N class is -1 where
n is the number of distance label
moving forward let's fit and transfer
data for training
so here we will write for
I in
I in
range
0 comma five
X underscore train
comma I
equals to
label
encoder
underscore x dot fit
transform
and X underscore train
colon comma I
and X underscore train
seven
equals to
but
order
underscore X
dot fit
transform
and X underscore train
seven
let's see X underscore
oh sorry
train
and yeah this I
it is capital X
we transform joins these two steps and
is used for the initial fitting of the
parameter on the trading set
while also returning the transformed X
internally the transfer object just
calls first fit and then transform on
the same data and we will
perform same for the Y
so
I have I will write here
table
encoder underscore y
EP so label
label
encoder
okay
Pi underscore chain
equals to label
encoder
underscore y Dot
fit
underscore transform
you see the results yeah
so training of the data set is done
let's do for same for this testing data
so I will write here for
I in
range
0
comma five
underscore test
I
equals to
label
order
underscore X
Dot fit underscore
transform
is underscore
test
of I
then again
X underscore test
column comma seven
equals to
label
encoder
underscore
Dot
fit
underscore transform
underscore
test
then colon comma seven
yeah and see the results X underscore
test
okay it seems good
all the values
so we will do for the same y test
so we will write here label
encoder
let me put
let's go why
because you label
so y underscore test was to
um
but border
underscore y dot bit
score
transform
underscore test
let's see
okay
moving forward we will import standard
scalar for the further process
so for that we will write here
from sqlan
Dot preprocessing
port
Stan done
scalar
says equals to
like really assign this standard
I will do I will copy it from here
so X strain
equals to SS dot fit
underscore transform
X underscore
trained
then X underscore test equals to SS Dot
with
underscore transform
X underscore test
okay
dot preprocessing
okay sqlnp processing
standard scalar
okay sorry
and again like standard okay
ER
yeah so standard scalar removes the mean
and scales each feature variable to unit
variance
this operation is performed feature wise
in an independent way everything is done
let's see which classifier is best for
prediction by seeing their accuracy
so for that
I will write here
let me do one thing
yeah
so like I will write from
you learn
dot ensemble
symbol yeah
import
random
Forest
classifier
so I will write if under
class clf classifier
equals to
random Forest
sorry my bad
so RF
underscore clf
dot fit
X underscore train
comma y underscore train
so I will write here from
SK learn import
s
y underscore prediction
equals to RF underscore
classifier
dot predict
dot predict
X underscore test
so here I will print
accuracy
of Random
random Forest
classifier is
comma Matrix
a DOT accuracy
score score
then y
underscore prediction
comma y underscore test
why underscore prediction
so let's see the prediction from the
using random Forest classifier
and the accuracy a random for it is a
meta estimator that employs averaging to
increase predicted accuracy and reduce
overfitting
if both type equals to true the size of
this subsample is determined by the max
sample argument otherwise each tree is
constructed using the entire data set
so here you can see the accuracy is like
78 percent
and here prediction you can see like
here one denotes that loan approved and
zero means loan will not approve
so accuracy is quite less so let's see
for another classification methods name
base
so here I will write from sqlan
port
gaussian
NB nav base
okay so NB classifier
plus two
gaussian
NB
B underscore classifier
equals to
sorry dot fit
strain
comma y
train
so
a not equals to
like gaussian okay G's capital
sorry
so let's predict the value
y underscore predict
let's do NB
a scope classifier
dot predict
X underscore
test
and print
accuracy
of
nav base
is
comma like Matrix
dot accuracy
score score
y underscore prediction
comma y underscore test accuracy of
gaussian NB is 0.8 means 82 percent
let's predict the value by predict
the prediction like one is like loan
approved and 0 is loan or not approved
so nav base is a classification
algorithm for binary two classes and
multi-classes classification problem it
is called name based the calculation of
the probabilities for each class as
simplified to make that calculation
tractable
so the accuracy is 82 percent and here
prediction you can see one denotes loan
approved and 0 means loan will not
approve so let's see for another
classification method like decision tree
classifier
for that I will write here
from
SK learn
dot tree
import
decision
tree
classifier
here I will write DT underscore
classifier
equals to
I will copy it from here
I will write here DT underscore clf
equals to
dot fit
X underscore train
comma y underscore train
y small
here I will
see the accuracy
pursue DT
underscore classifier
dot predict
underscore
test
so here I will print
accuracy of
dysentery is
comma Matrix
dot accuracy
underscore
underscore predict
comma y underscore test
so here you can see the accuracy is 70
percent
so let me predict
so decently the non-parametric
supervised learning approach used for
classification and regression
application
it is organized hierarchically as and
has a note Road branches internal nodes
and Lead nodes this so the accuracy 70
and here prediction you can see one
denotes the loan approved and 0 means
loan will not approve so let's do one
more classification we will do it from
the K neighbors using K Neighbors
over here we will write
from
kailan
Dot
burst
import
K Neighbors
pacifier
kn classifiers
we will assign
this
so here we will write KN underscore
classifier
Dot
bit
x and double strain
comma y underscore chain
okay s k learn
sorry
then again
okay it's Capital here
Capital here
yeah
so here I will see the accuracy
okay
my prediction it was so
kn
underscore classifier
Dot
predict
X underscore test
print
here AC
of
K neighbors is
Matrix
dot accuracy
score score
by underscore prediction
comma y
underscore test
so let's see the accuracy so accuracy is
79 percent and it is quite good so the K
numbers the five closed neighbors are
sought for the K numbers classifier the
classifier must be explicitly instructed
to utilize euclidean distance to
determine the proximity of nearby points
so the accuracy is 79 percent and here
prediction you can see one denotes the
loan approved and zero means loan will
not approve
so you can see
nav base
name is yeah so here you can see
we have name base classifier with the
best accuracy of 82 percent so we can
use it for the loan approval prediction
system
we will go through the hands of lab demo
of how you can detect Parkinson's
disease using machine learning
we will perform different function and
analyze the data set using python to
find who has Parkinson's disease and who
has not using different different python
libraries
before we move on to the programming
part so here is one question for you
guys
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right or wrong
so the question is
which of the following characters used
to give single line comments in Python
option A double slash option b hash
option C star option D slash star let us
know your answer in the chat section
so I am starting the timer of one minute
you can just type your answer in the
comment section or in the chat section
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
let us know in your answer in the chat
section
foreign
characters used to give single line
comments in Python
double slash has star slash star
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this
each of the following characters is used
to give single line comments in Python
15 seconds remaining which of the
following characters used to give single
line commands in Python
one
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one now let's move to our
programming part to implement
prediction system of Parkinson's disease
so first we will open a command prompt
to write command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select a new Python 3
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a prediction
system of Parkinson's disease
so I will write here first I will rename
this
foreign
so I will write here
quote
numpy
as NP
and the second one is import
pandas as PD
and the next one is
from sqln
port
svm
then from
SK learn
dot matrix
import
accuracy
underscore then score
after that from
Escalon
Dot pre-processing
import
standard
scalar
then from
SK learn
dot model
underscore selection
port
train
underscore test
underscore split
then press enter yeah
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has function
for working in the domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the second version pandas
panda is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time series
Escalon the most effective and reliable
python machine learning library is
called sqln or scikit-learn
through a python consistency interface
it offers a variety of effective tools
for statical modeling and machine
learning including classification
regression and many more
svm svmr utilized in web pages and
chosen detection phase identification
email Gene classification and
handwriting recognition
among other applications we utilize svm
in machine learning for some reason
including this
both classification and regression
linear and non-linear data are supported
sqln mattresses the sqln matrices module
implements several laws score and
utility function to measure
classification performance
some matrices might require probability
estimate of the positive class
configuration value or binary decision
value
and the next one is accuracy score in
Python the accuracy score function of
the sqln matrices package calculates the
accuracy score for a set of predicted
labels against the true labels
SQL and pre-processing the SQL and
pre-processing package offers a number
of universal utility function and
Transformer classes to modify
unprocessed feature vectors into a
format better suited for the subsequent
estimators in general standardizing the
data set in advantages for learning
algorithm
then standard scalar each feature of
variable is scaled to unit variance once
standard scalar has its move this mean
this process is carried out
independently based on features since
standard scalar estimate the empirical
mean and standard deviation of each
feature if they are present in the data
set
and the last one is train test split
python train test split method divides
array or matrices into random sepsis
for the train and test set of data we
will import the train test split
function into our application as shown
import the train test split variable
from the sqln model selection
so after importing major libraries let's
import data set so for that we will
write here
DF equals to
PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSV
then data set name
disease
dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below so let's see our
data set now so here I will write DF
so this is how our data set looks like
with 195 rows and 24 columns
okay
so here you can see like we can't see
all the 195 rows okay like top five rows
and
so
here you can see the three dots
this three dots what if I want to see
all the 195 rows so for that I will
write here
Ed dot set
let's go option
display
dot Max
underscore columns
here I will write PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
close
comma none
and here I will write the data set name
DF
yeah
so you can see now we are unable to see
the all the 195 rows
okay
all the 195 rows
so moving forward we will use head
function to see only top five rows
so first I will do like this
okay here I will write
DF dot hat
so here you can see we can see only top
five rows of our data set
so
so basically head is used for showing
first five rows of the data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show last five rows of the data
set
so let's move forward and see
and using info function to see the
information about the data set so I will
write here DF dot info
yeah
so the data frame information is printed
by the info method the data includes the
total number of columns their labels
data kinds memory use raise index and
the number of cells in each column like
non-null values note that the info
method does not indeed print the
information
okay so we all know all the column names
and the data types so here you can see
these are the column names and non-null
values then data types
okay
yeah so moving forward let's see some
statical values using describe function
so for that I will write DF Dot describe
press enter yeah
so here you can see all the statical
values of every column like mean is
standard deviation count like 25 percent
50 percent 75 percent the maximum value
of that particular column okay for every
column
so moving forward let's see how many
columns and rows are present in the data
set using the shape function
for that I will write here
DF dot shape
so here you can see we have 195 rows and
24 columns present in our data set
okay like 190 it represents
rows and this represents columns okay
so moving forward we will see how many
null values are present in the data set
so for that we will write
DF dot is null
then dot sum
then press enter
is showing data frame objects here oh
sorry for that
this is is null
yeah then press enter yeah
so here you can see there is no null
values present in our data set no zero
zero zero all the zeros are here
so we can say this is a good data set
okay
so I will this
yeah so moving forwards we will
distribute our Target variable columns
okay
so for that I have to write here DF
status
status is our Target variable okay
Target column
dot value
underscore
counts
and press enter yeah
so here you can see zeros and ones like
147 ones and zeros are zero sorry 48 are
0.
so one means those who are affected by
the Parkinson and 0 means negative those
who are not affected by the Parkinson's
disease
so moving forward what we will do we
will group data based on the target
variable okay so for that I have to
write here DF dot Group by
then status
dot mean
yeah
so here you can see that we group data
based on the target variable for each
column for each column
all the 24 columns okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code like any code till
here
so you can just put us in comments or
our team will surely provide you the
correct solution okay
so moving forward like we what we will
do we will separate features and Target
variable
so what we will do we will drop the two
columns like first one is name column
and the second one is status column and
in another variable we will put status
column
let's see
I have to write x equals to
at d f dot drop
then columns
equals to
question is name
and the second one is
status
okay
comma X is equals to
1.
then in y
I will put
DF
status
so let's print X and Y
so I will print here
print
y here
yeah
so here you can see
all the X values
and here you can see all these status
value like zeros and ones only
zeros and ones okay
let me do this yeah
so moving forward we will split data set
into training and testing using train
test split function
so for that we will write
X
underscore train
comma X
underscore test
comma
y underscore train
comma
y underscore test
also
train underscore test underscore split
comma y comma
test
underscore
size
was to 0.2
comma
random underscore State equals to 2.
yeah
so here what I did I split training and
testing data into 80 and 20 ratio 80 for
training data and twenty percent for
testing
in prediction like this is the best
ratio
so moving forward let's see how many
rows and columns are present in training
data and in testing data so for that I
have to write your print
dot shape
comma
X underscore train
dot shape
comma X underscore test dot shift
yeah
so here you can see
like in training and testing there are
22 columns why because we already
dropped two columns name and status
okay let me show you first
and we checked this before there are 24
columns okay
so now we have only 22 volumes why
because we dropped the name and Status
column
so X train has 156 rows this 156 rows
why this is 80 percent of 195. okay and
this is 20 of 195. this is training this
is testing
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code or any machine
learning topic and python so you what
you can do just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward what we will do we
will do data standardization okay
so the process of transforming data into
a standardized format so that user may
process and evaluate it is known as data
standardization
most businesses use data from a variety
of sources including databases data
warehouse Lakes cloud storage and
storage areas
okay so for that I will write SS equals
to
standard
killer
we all know what is standard scalar
yeah so press enter
so we use a standard scalar for it so I
will write here SS dot pit
then X underscore train SS means
standard scalar okay
don't confuse yeah so using standard
scalar we fit training data into it so
moving forward we will transform
training data and testing data using
standard scalar Library okay so I will
write here x underscore train
equals to SS dot transform
portray
yeah
then X underscore test
equals to SS SS means standardscaler dot
transform
test
yeah then press enter
so transformation is done now let's see
our training and testing data for that I
will write here print
X underscore train
so this is our training data
and print
X underscore test
so this is our testing data okay
yeah so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or any machine
learning topic just put us in comments
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution so moving forward we
will train our model using svm method
svmr utilized in web pages intrusion
dissection page identification email
Gene classification and handwriting
recognition among other application we
utilize svms in machine learning for
some reason including this
okay so we will do model training using
like svm so I will write a model
equals to
svm dot SVC
that will write a kernel
question
linear
and press enter
okay
sqln.svm has no attribute SVC okay my
bad
C is capital
okay let me check
okay
should be small
then press enter yeah now it's working
fine
so let's train svm with training data so
for that I will write here
model dot fit
X
underscore train
comma y underscore train then press
enter
yeah it's working fine
so moving forward what we will do we
will do model evaluation so for that I
have to write here x underscore
then train
underscore
prediction
equals to model Dot
predict
X underscore train
train underscore data
accuracy equals to accuracy
underscore score
y underscore train
and then
X underscore train
then
prediction
let me do one thing I have to write D
here
for the better understanding
yeah then press enter from this we what
we are doing we are doing prediction and
checking the accuracy of the model svm
so like we will check accuracy for both
training and testing data okay yeah so
let me check first print
curacy of
training
data
data
here I have to write train
underscore data
underscore
accuracy
press enter
so the accuracy of training data is
almost 89 percent like which is not a
bad number
so let's check accuracy of the testing
data
so for that I have to write here x
underscore test underscore prediction
equals to model
dot predict
then X
test underscore data
underscore accuracy
equals to accuracy
score
y underscore test
comma
X underscore test
prediction
yeah
so now let's see the accuracy of testing
data so for that type light print
accuracy of testing
data
test
code data underscore accuracy
so here you can see the accuracy of
testing data is almost 88 percent so
we're done with the model building and
the accuracy part so let's build
predictive system now okay for that
I will write
okay first let me do one thing yeah
so I will write here input
data
okay
then we will change data into numpy
array so for that we will write input
underscore data underscore NP equals to
NP dot as array
foreign
input
underscore data
okay
so now what we will do
we will reshape this array okay we will
receive this numpy array for that I will
write input underscore
data
underscore for a shape I will write only
re
so input
underscore data
let's go NP
dot reshape
then
1 2
minus 1.
okay
so now we will standardize the data for
that I will write here s underscore data
equals to SS dot transform
input
underscore data
foreign
so now I will make prediction model
prediction equals to
model dot predict
the standardized digital so as data
so you have to print
question
so for that I have to write here if
if prediction
0 equals to equals to zero
okay
then it should be print print
negative
no
Parkinson's
okay
else
print
positive
Parkinson
Parkinson's found
so we are done with the our coding part
so what we will do I will go on the my
data set
open with Notepad
so this is our data set okay we will put
any random value
like this value okay
yeah
put it here
so here you can see the status value to
the zero
so
zero means negative no Parkinson found
it should print no Parkinson found so
what I will do I will remove this to
check whether model is giving
the right answer or wrong
then press enter yeah
here you can see it printed Parkinson
found
so now we will check from the another
one
we'll take the random
we'll pick
this one
okay
I will remove this status value
then press enter
okay something error one error picture
okay okay okay
let me copy it again
the
then copy it again here
we'll remove this
and then press enter
yeah
here you can see positive Parkinson
found because there is one status is one
so so you can see the results are coming
amazing and correct so we came to the
end of this full course if you have any
queries you can ask in the comment
section below our team will respond you
as soon as possible and if you want this
full code just comment for the same
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this live session please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
give a like to this video thank you and
keep learning
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here